on salue youtube sa lutte wichita lui
tout le monde salue femmes
ok vous savez tout le monde fabre c'est
la grande saison qui démarre ça y est le
retour
le retour de ce pitch est ce procès que
de dire le retour du pingouin la fin fut
parfois plus d'un quand il est revenu et
ce que batman sera on ne sait pas quoi
sera toujours là ça c'est sûr mais bon
un batman
quelles sont ses rêves se réalisent
intéressés réel projet et qu'on ne sait
pas quoi c'est un milliardaire flore ne
sais pas ouais mais bon je les aime bien
qu'on non moi aussi j'aime bien matane
j'aime bien batman jamais sûr que plus
que d'autres
alors plus que qui puisque le bouffon
vert plus que le bouffon vert plus que
ça c'est mon super héros préférés quoi a
donc on lui fait une grande confiance
qu'à ce batman à la baisse j'aime bien
s'il n'a pas de pouvoir tu vas pas par
des tricheurs mais il faut il donne tout
quand elle se bat à y donne tout ce
qu'il a d'ailleurs demandé mon il est
contre superman l'avons tu vas pour moi
c'est si j'avais été metteur en scène de
batman qu'on superman pour voir le film
dure trois minutes en certainement
superman vient en fait ouais superman
n'a pas trouvé de défoncer normalement
j'aurais pas film complètement différent
que superman arrive j'ai le droit à quoi
non vous n'êtes que des humains jeu
c'était génial
ce temps a été plus logique en fait hein
c'est ça que malgré sa grosse armure
normalement ça c'est pas mais bon le cap
tony tan c'est bon pas tout le monde à
la kryptonite un genre toi par exemple
est ce que tu en kryptonite la benne ont
malheureusement n'ont pas cessé parti
attend normand attends moi c'est pas
partie malgré ce pas partie ben je sais
pas je vois des coûts bouger
j'ai suivi qu'à roanne en la sagesse
comme ça y est donc c'est un début réty
non attends attends attends tu en fais
pas partie je parle quand même
combien on est là dans le live naissante
5 déjà c'est bien partager quoi par les
enfants sont nombreux comme suit ce gros
match merci dieu le fils keto noës à
réty double fond de kyoto à des rejets
mehdi qui m'appelait de telle heure
était très fier est ce que bon il a joué
des groupes tout l'été bon il me dit mon
mail heureusement je peux 35 points elo
mais bon quand même j'ai représenté mais
il a surtout vu de guise a déjoué une
nuque grise et g45 fou gedo qui a eu
lieu au 7e pourrait comprendre l'idée
évidemment flash 4 pour pas qu'ils kg 6
et puis à mais bon après comité pas trop
à l'aise parce que les noirs ont fait
des 5 10 bompas que vous faites et du
coup il a fait 2 3 des 3a 3b quatre
foulées 2 qui avaient lieu deux cahiers
des deux ça va il a gagné lui qui était
mieux et qu'il a fait nul après c'était
contre l'isabelle malassagne et je dis
oui ben voilà partis présents pour la
faire sur la chaîne hbo you really et ça
tiens regarde lui aussi quoi tu parles
pas innocemment frontier tôt je sais que
à 10 ans et gruissan arriver quoi c'est
très violent va être calmes ouverture
c'est cette semaine d'hommages de
dévoiler les prépas pour son match
contre contre 45,1 points mais bon du
coup peut-être suivre les parties de
mehdi je concède lui tire son
inspiration quoi je tiens mes dix
nouveaux un nouveau seconde en bas il
avait quasi milanais dominguez
il a des mecs à 2500 vont qui ne servent
à rien qu'ils sont que la vie a feeling
leur douleur mais mehdi par contre mais
non là les idées on prend ma jolie tenue
en totalité et qu'enfin je remédie au
dessus de tout quoi de chantal coach de
soirée coach
coach de g kwh a fait naître midi
derrière vlad quoi ce serait une échelle
à 2 une fusée à 2 à 2 la deux et accroît
encore et encore plus cacher quoi
ouais c'est un peu comme l'équipe sky tu
as cdg qui intrigue elle aussi dans la
fusée quoi elle pourrait être en veille
pour traduire par contre pour traduire
très important parce que j'arrive à
gérer il parle français mais ils y vont
pour traduire trois quarts mais ptet
traduit il te chauffe pour la boxe faim
partout quoi donc cette partie
il vient de faire à 4 et j'imagine fable
que l'idée sur b4 c'est de faire des
cinq équipes et 6 4 6 4
ouais bah j'aime bien énorme et je dois
te dire que je serais pour les 20 ans
dans ce match ben moi aussi une femme
pour votre joie raconte carole nomme mes
bourreaux nous on aime bien non mais je
suis très énervé de sa date de son
élimination l'année dernière encore sur
facture on n'a pas pu voir tout son
potentiel
ce qu'il a perdu maintenant de me pose
cette histoire de déconnexion et
j'aurais bien aimé la fin je suis un peu
de frustration l'an dernier par rapport
à ça et du coup j'ai très envie de le
voir cette année aller ou pourquoi pas
aller au bout comprenant un passer
quelques tours je veux des gros matches
et tous aveugles parce qu'en fait
caruana de toute façon pas on sait qu'en
glisse donc et puis là le match contre
eux car tu sais j'en prépare toi pour
son match contre 15 cents chèvres à la
feta life
nous nous mais pourra revenir à feu je
pense qu'on est la seule chaîne des
fours pour un joueur pas les autres nous
prônons sais pas mais moi si moi je dis
pas on n'est pas journaliste voiture
toute objectivité je te dirai pas du
coup on n'a pas eu notre objectif alors
je mette un lien dans le chatt fab vers
le poste facebook pour faire des
partages ce qui est très très peu de
l'ail qu'on n'a jamais vu aussi peu de
light et de partage depuis toute
l'histoire des speechs s1 mais bon je
vois chaque fois les mecs me dire oui
mes amis ne joue pas d'échec mais on
s'en fout on va partager quand même
qu'est ce que c'est beaucoup dire quand
les gens verront ils viendront pas il
suffit garder un oeil qui viennent de
sainte-thérèse qui vont repartager tout
de suite fait 50 personnes en plus
orange fait des vidéos youtube parce que
moi de base j'ai que cinq amis qui
jouent aux échecs
bref tout ça sert à quoi fin pourquoi tu
fais des vidéos youtube peut faire froid
sera jouée du tournoi d'échecs
d'ailleurs ses amis ne joue pas contre
eux qui vas tu joues échographe tu
arrives dans le tournoi passer à
d'autres personnes ah merde donc voilà
je ne veux plus de cette excuse que vous
nous dites oui non j'ai la flemme juste
pour lui appuie sur le bouton c'est trop
compliqué bon l'arrêt ensemble on
pourrait répondre à ce moment là mais
leurs excuses non je n'ai pas d'amis non
non non non non mais c'est vrai que
c'est l'excusé un peu facile genre bah
je peux tu peux répondre ça tout le
temps à tout le temps pas plus vous
découvrir des amis qui viennent les
échecs qui vont pas se cacha jusque là
dessus mais je n'osais pas parce que je
croyais boutiques n'avaient pas d'amis
qui jouent enfin sa progression dans la
main tout ça enfin je pense qu'avec la
panetière saguenay serge l'impression de
passer pour un fragile ange pauvreté
chez sais que je vais peur de le dire
bravo
ok j'ai la flemme bah voilà enfin moi je
préfère une réponse à leurs attaques
genre j'ai la flemme futur j'en ai rien
à [ __ ] de vos de vos vidéos de merde
tu vas à la limite je préfère en fait on
aime le maître des côtes pas n'y aurait
peut-être eu un fils très grand samus
filtration alors cette infiltration ses
pions à la qui a infiltré mon fab celle
qui aura 70 entre mai
watteau reprendre mais peut-être pioncer
6 on ne s'est pas bâti station va sauter
du coup on fait quoi on fait un truc
comme apprendre et on prend ces six là
il veut faire trop con vaisselle comment
repenser à bétou reprend mois tacler
d'avoir bougé cette dame est alors où ça
plateau 30 et 6 h qu'il va s'en prendre
à ses 6 et du coup je sais pas je me
vient la pression d'un rognant fait bien
entendu partie dans les partages l'epa
partagent surtout les pats partage du
coût et des puits entre temps car on a
trouvé du jeu mais en fait tu avec
l'exacte ans conduisait donc on peut ne
pas suivre la partie et puis quand même
tu vas voir tous les bons coups et est
donc il va récupérer des 6 6 1 puis
prend du cavaly tu sais prendre mes
membres mais peut-être légalisé par yan
wei jiafu prend ses six tours ses sept
tours à huit déjà qui peut mettre tout
repenser citroën et on pensait il dit en
rencontres décisives tourcoing est
fluide échec et on reprend des six qui
était pas mal mais ok vous prend ses six
tombes et 6 ouais il prend 17 nancy ne
vient tourner mais attends t'es tu fais
tous ses sept tours à la limite non mais
tu m'aimes pas clair enfin tu y es tour
des huit tours à huit qui est bien vite
du coup vous un peu tristounet mais what
else
by ap read adam hockey parme et ont
cessé d entreprendre des pins mais
peut-être un guide vers un trip et là je
me dis tour c'est cette non ouais pour
ces sept îles près aux quads en bessin
que j'imagine comme 60 ans prendre ses
quatre tours à 8 mai n'est surtout pas
en france à 4 des 5 plus faire des jeux
hors dom le bon c'est la même tendance
et quatre sur le mans tours à huit à
temps et c'est la main écartant non en
fait on est là où poussent ici ça aurait
pu les fous j'ai deux coiffeurs
il ya un truc qu'on n'est pas close et
pas trop compris mais il a réfléchi
avant donc un truc qu'on a ratées je
pense à lui tous ces sacs non bon ça
ressemble bon pour la médaille c'est
cette date être un truc de fou une jeune
dame prend et fugues et prend et fut
deux fois 3 3 ça n'avait pas marché
il y aura du hachis sous coin des ash
ouais mais attends c'est chaud puisqu'il
a dû tout reprendre et fitou ravi tirs
menaçants
je sais pas qui est mieux la monf a bon
tu peux changer la donne quand même pas
te faire mater sur la huitième ouais
mais bon on sait pas mais les fous sont
comme à ces formes non c'est chaud c'est
chaud c'est chaud on m'a bien que la
tour c 4 robin sort des 8e mais on a un
peu loin ok peut-être d'impro des six
des 44 ans s'est vite apprendre ici seul
avantage c'est que ça permette aussi de
quoi ça permet pas de couvrir à 3 et
fuite quoi les tours ceci mutsch
direction passif un peu mais bon ok on
défend quant à canal+ avec les noix
ouais on a là qu'une pions b3 quoi enfin
qui peut faire des servir à contre jour
ma rancoeur caronna et un plus gros lots
chess comme que les bonnes je suis un
peu surpris un mal fou aux quatre pieds
pour quatre tours et fuite
il doit prendre des cavaliers à 12,04
j'aime pas trop se prendre la fuite
n'oubliez rendu cavaliers sur propre
intimâtes il va menacer des sept des
huit arbres à 7,17 bien un révolté et
prend des sept îles vautours à huit
échecs
cavalia fuite et foix iii matin était un
truc de fouine du bon vous obtenez un
très bon match on sait où va faire à
chaud au coeur de voir bob le monde
ouais mais tourcoing f8 échec est bon il
aima leurs potes du coup mais quelque
chose de nul est-ce que tu as deux pions
pour la pièce pavillon b 3 est ok a
concédé que des pions de storefront tour
ou des trucs comme ça à long terme
présents le long gagnant pour les blancs
mais bon je gagne et quand même mais
âgées il est ce qui fâche 4 du coût ou
tu gardes de karachi gf2 tu fais même
fougue et de la wii 2 5
je vais 200g torje quatre fins avec tata
gt tour 2 du coup tu es fou b2 âge et
ses tours 2 ça ok to b de cinq toros et
alors peut-être mais tour de queen ok je
prends bon ok c'est quand même dur à
défendre que cette seconde à prendre le
jaune à laymont impossible le nepad
arménien hak b 2 1 c'est pas mal joué
c'est surtout angers 7 3 6 et du coup à
la drac jeu soit non ouais mais surtout
pranger set je pense que faire un truc
de fouine
je crois que je vais faire rager 6
tourcoing f2 en fait ils te gagnerai
venus en force
ok bon ça se je pense à faire l'addition
voiture maire de soues décrétant un
amendement
est ce qu'ils vont changer la règle pour
éviter la technique j'ai toujours quoi
non c'était en temps un peu un bruit de
ventilo appuyé par ses 60 ans en europe
a encore son ordi qui me vont ils
causent un ouais j'ai lancé le ventilo
parce que parce que le devon chaque fois
il tente le truc données g7 pour faire
prendre 5 au bon moment mon cas ça va
donc 1-0 caruana balle au centre
bah bah oury bolos en trombe enfin pas
encore balle au centre arrive alors je
crois que faire un petit break main
entre les parties par contre les jets
quoi enfin disons qu'avant il enchaîné
tout de suite dans la seconde à venir la
tenant il vers 5-6 monde dehors
oui d'accord c'est vraiment deux petits
mois et donc c'est toujours la même
règle 1h30 de 5 + 1
une heure de 3 + 1 et une demi-heure 2 1
+ 1 est ok bonne partie de carlingue
donc qu'est ce que c'est que ça et
françaises ils ont vu la vie nation
meilleur la phaser les mecs
en fait il ya link intéressant que te
faire d'âme des uns une fois que c'est
fait il va regarder ça c'est un polonais
je serai fuite c'est dans un f2
moskalenko à toi ça intéressant parce
qu'ils aient des idées stratégiques avec
les nerfs bien sûr tu juste la structure
pions qu'en fait tu étais pas de tir en
campagne prend date accouplements tu
peux tu vas à droite à gauche tu
navigues femmes c'est que t'as pas les
tours lié tout ça mais j'étais pas à
l'e3 de juin
j'ai fait deux parties deux nuls sont
des mecs mal classés et jeu des foyers
des ventes sont pas si mal et que tu
sont parfaitement que c'est pas pour ton
s'il n'était pas pour moi c'est au tour
à schwyz qui joue jamais fait alors
attendre 40 trous pour avoir joué votre
courage si ce projet fera je sais pas
quoi je sais pas j'ai donc voilà du coup
là il va faire préférer cavale f5 défend
risque avec les bleus on peut essayer de
décaler la dame jorda match 3 préparer
du g4 mais pas maradona mais quelle rage
sans que ces thématiques afrique c'est
que c'est pas trop le chassé par geci ce
qui revient à m6 quoi c'est cool on
faisait ça éclate à madame l'attaquent
la dame médecin je t'ai parlé d'une
partie par équipes là qu'il est dur et
150 kw avec je joue en allemagne
ouais c'est à peu près ça fait 6 5 6 4
juste tout est bloqué les leroy s'est
fait bloquer aussi jean les bleus ont
fait quatre morts chez 6 h 5 juin ne
vous gênez pas le très lent qu'on est ce
qu'une trucs comme cal arrange et 7 là
ça se regarde à l'elysée de mettre le
fou un déficit saturé
je sais pas voilà ça marche rarement mon
avis puisque tours h7 qui a 17 tu veux
tout va très vite mais mais c'est pas
con de regarder enfin toute façon si ça
marche tant mieux ça marche pas battu
en outre au tout et tu le pauvre un truc
là comme d'âme des uns fait pour
protéger le pion et préparé j'ai quatre
séjours et d'ailleurs m
cela donne souvent revient bien en fait
on était les faits le bourget car ce que
tu atteins allait bien mais à tête
blanche étudiait des fantômes est
d'abord là énorme ce qui fait ce qu'a
fait rare elle me demanda s'il ramène
qui ans et 6 à 5 c 4
il est le dernier des 17 plus tôt pour
couvrir met donc à prendre f4 f5 points
j'aime beaucoup les blancs ici femmes
mais après ce qu'on peut faire f5 la
direccte tracter chose 9,5 bas il va
résister
ryback je pense le faire relève et
peut-être après j'ai h mais là tu as
honte tu veux pas être un conte force
mais c'est le problème c'est pour
pallier ce qui est 10 à 2 début mais là
c'était ce que te faire grand cas
mais malheureusement le roi est revenu
sur sa case de départ
enfin pourquoi pas quoi pourquoi tour
n'ont pas bougé il tourne pas voulu de
façon non mais j'aime pas du tout les
bas fonds qu'il trouve une défense je ne
sais pas le même c'est hyper passif
maintenant en plus même f6 doit peut
être idiot pour jouer stratégique à
l'espace mais normalement je voudrais
bien appuyé de liens que je prendrais
j'ai négocié qui prend du cavalier tu
reviens que sur le cahier ci prend du
pion c'est horrible non mais affligé six
appareils plus gros avantage
enfin pas tous les coups un peu de même
tu peux garder l'attention peut être un
peu fait faire du dôme b1
j'ai pas juste une tchèque un peu tu
veux des logettes dam des trois tout à
finale s'il veut pas tuer ses quatre
tours encore un autre front est
peut-être la ferme damas il a vu six de
f3 qui peut arriver quand il y aurait
trois fuites mef l'emmo nat et partout
où touristes sont de f mais comme ça
feeling ans de cavale et je pouvais le
voir d'autres revenir acheter
non mais t'es mal la femme un abri
l'ate est au bord un bellâtre et tous
les inconvénients de la variante les
tours pallier tout ça comme dit quoi les
noirs en fait peuvent pas supporter ça
la foule juste prendre un avantage
stratégique important et eu à défendre
défendre la patrie grinta finale mais là
je vois même pas l'entente stratégique
post je suis en train de mettre un peu
le visage des joueurs fab sur les jeta
un peu perdu de son chalet perdu de son
bois ou chevaux qui parlait plus loin je
parlais plus en fait je n'ai perdu de
son annonce et non mais j'étais en train
pour les gens du nord kivu à l'est les
visages des joueurs paraissent que l'on
notait tonfas cam la main non non on ne
s'est pas tu vas fin fut pas notre dv4
visage
non mais je peux et je ne veux pas faire
ça fait trop de visages pas sa mère trop
de visages aperçu rebond de suivre les
parties à papa il sait plus quoi suivre
après mam après on a trop sur l'écran
farage match je regardais le tour de
france avait montré un commentateur et
les cyclistes vont pas montré tous les
gens bien le mec sur scène que sur la
moto tour l'équipe
si tout cela à l'écran de partout peut
enfin fut le directeur sportif qui part
j'ai contré par chrono pour des petites
fenêtres parcours qu'on a le chronomètre
est officiel il reste 1h12 de cinq
minutes de cinq minutes bah c'est pas le
tour à doha les mecs qui les fait jouer
plein de ronde ils enchaînent enfin
j'adore trop peu je sais pas est-ce
qu'il faut un truc mon jour de repos
parce qu'il ya des simultanée des gens
de torchwood des enfants des femmes des
chèques tu as un truc parce que la
rigueur c'est pour expliquer mais c'est
un repos pour dormir
la bouffe lessard et là ça notre place
est passé de spécial
après ils le font un peu de partout il
n'y a pas un truc eric daman 4 ce qui va
arriver montfavet tour est venu en
premier pour défendre moi qu'il ya une
chance que vous balader crise qu'il a
trouvé quelque chose même si c'est très
fin mais vos j'appelle le truc décisif
encore c'est pas bizarre son kg 3 il
vient pas encore finalisé ouais mais la
donne va revenir donne
je descends ce qui aurait pu checker
avec tous rêvent de et préparer quoi
s'en sortira jamais ok c'est ça son
niveau a moqué sur l'abc une vraie fin
août ou réfère d'abord pour éviter d'
adam f 7 et bien spartine démonstration
pour l'instant estivades précis jusqu'au
bout on va voir mais l'instance il joue
vite en plus sérieuse contre hull quoi
toi aussi surnaturelle ci seraient
parqués h5 assez pédagogique et g8 mc
alger qui est quand même mais fois qu'il
prend h5n1
mais ok peut-être ça va suffire mais
chez bon ok mais tu peux faire tahir
alam à chis matray
bon les seconds une menace certifié trop
rien tour 8 aussi par sa question puisse
enfin me posais femmes huit mois je
défends mon cavalier j'aime bien parce
que peut-être tu menaces tour projet 6
par foyer s'est rendu qu'à veille pour
la fourche à prendre adams est en l'air
mais c'est pas dit des trucs 3,8 pour le
mode et enchaîne avec certains regardent
un peu car oneapp ce qui bouge pas alors
qu'il menace d'un match 4 en fait tout
est fluide jaune
ok je ferais damas quatre prises
cavaliers dame prend au jeu c'est
dommage 6 est supprimée temps je prends
du cavalier et d'un match 4 du coût du
couple aux quatre vents jusqu'à tu mets
associés peut-être points à 8 46 dans
machete
dommage car j'aime bien je fasse une
dépense plus de mach 4 4,5 pour prend au
kg 5 mai donne projet cadre du coup je
pense donc et j'essaie d'être je crois
pardon excuses
c'est bien filmé minimum tour points
inscrits mais c'est vraiment si je suis
on peut faire mieux que ça mais bon au
profit d'un problème c'est quelque chose
dans la gamme airdream ouais ouais
dommage et ou pas possible clip si c'est
quand même quoi karine leroy de boxer
dans son coin
si ce temps jean ait mené jusqu'à vaille
f6 damage 5 d'un match 7 matt aussi aux
pcgr
mais quelle défense quand même c'est ce
robuste la française comme mais du coup
y'a pas à 100 je ne fais pas le mec qui
s'appelle le même prénom que toi et je
voulais même couverture que toi t'as pas
envie d'être pour lui voilà quelque part
son alter ego plus il a mis les drapeaux
croate sur twitter mais elle n'a pas
apprécié sa famille royale et robuste
qu'adam g et six dames dames christelle
et g4 et je joue au final le pion
j'échange toubab des transports aux g2g
préfère non mais elle doit gagner mais
géré par là que pas assez choquant même
de défendre aussi longtemps intel
poubelle ce que peut-être je défends un
an le roi angers saint vallier faire
même nom mais l'échangé de sanctions
afin d'en manquer si le roi n'en est
arrivée jusqu'en f5
non mais ok on va monter non non mais là
ça va aller là mais je change tout drôle
ouais mais attend il veut faire un truc
de fou il met sa part walid et syrte
cinq essais sur l'option passer une
soirée quatre à quatre oui mais il
bloque tout le bloc total avant et je
pars et tu as dno h5 va monter hk tâche
et ce en quoi je synchronise peu près
aussi ses propres contenus
mais que des forains d'ailleurs des deux
côtés un beaucoup d'efforts aussi pour
pour caroline dans la première ouais
donc tu vois la différence c'est
qu'avant il redémarre est vraiment
direct direct quoi c'est pas mal c'est
mieux quand je l'aï quand même 5 6
secondes de break mais c'est un peu trop
intense je pense aux formes
même quand on joue à nous mêmes la dap
rochestie surtout quand les télés les
samedis la hante l'europe du monde voit
dame en plus nous parfois on avait quand
même une pause entre les parties genre
suffisent à vous avez 4 5 minutes
parfois mais là oh là là je sais pas
comment mais et 5 ne tue pas il me
demande quels sont ceux qui envoient tu
as les couilles qui copie tout au fond
des systèmes de londres va faire un char
on n'en peut plus quoi s'arrêter de
jouer comme nous enfin non mais
intéressant avant baronian fait c'est
prendre et autres fous des six tout de
suite bon tu as un gros trou au 5 ta put
otis derrière mais si tu installe un
caméléon ou 4 ou tu fais f4 avec thé
noir tu mets jamais imposition des noirs
a là encore on va voir comment ça évolue
recense c'est pas mal comme match je
sais pas j'attends que caro n'y en ait
pas mal quand la première partie il a
juste bien bien fait mais jean st il
s'est fait un peu avoir des
complications et il est heureux du jeu
car on a la deuxième il a bien joué dans
la française et ouais à rognan bullet ça
donne quoi je crois qu'il est pas mal
n'est pas effacée cinéma turc à damas il
va faire quoi fouet quand il revient il
s'en fout mais faut une 3e martyrisé et
superman la terre voilà y'a pas de faim
tu as envie de kiev 3 c'est ce qu'il
veut faire
j'ai cinq étrangers sané d'accueil et
peut-être c'est que nul n'est pas
inquiet je peux montrer pourquoi tu dis
ça ok minutes c'est déjà très bien quoi
et en plus tu peux peut-être la jouer
enfin bivouac appuyé mais je m'aventure
va pas j'ai cinq ans maintenant mais
c'est tout en plus tu peux faire x 8 où
elle est salariée tu veux faire g5 à ce
moment là mais si tu joues à kiev 4 un
jour toi sont le fruit d'une rangée
système très bien joué de la part de la
remettre façon souvent danser danser
stonewall tu ramènes le fou en 8 pour
aller visage cinq bons car on va ça va
chauffer une pièce où j'ai pas le choix
une forte de robin kenny lala sacrifier
ou des vastes projets saint qui veut
tordre aux études non je serais venu
appareils pas comment il va faire
oui c'est sûr il va devoir donner mais
peut-être d'enfants carnage ou peuvent 4
au caisson à bertoua normal mais je
pense il ya peut-être pas envie de
prendre 4 5 qui est la dr magnus pas du
coup tu dois rien montré du coup tu aura
jamais rien mais il préfère faire autre
chose
ok donc sur g5y prime à quoi il va
envoyer deux partout n'est pas donné
mais c'est pas bon enfin c'est sur ces
produits il va prendre avec le fou non
plus tôt ouais bah c'est pas si sûr que
c'est pas assez faim bat angers ça mais
je veux pas faire de cinq trophées pas
pourquoi je préparerai jordi tour à 1,8
g 5 façon imparable
je vais le faire à un moment je me mets
bien en place pour huit matchs des
fantômes
un jour je prenais une pièce non non
mais je suis d'accord avec toi mais bon
je ne suis pas content du sud enfin pour
joue plus de londres on a même si c'est
pas les pièces à leur place normal ça
fait trois ans que j'ai deux fils est
venu de le voir en d3 et j'ai pas être
même à la mairie qu'il faut réussir un
sale un truc quand on veut saint claud
réussir à s'en prendre aux fouets f7 et
faire quelque chose mais je vois pas
comment pour leur part une chose qui a
une grosse poubelle je crois pas ou
alors peut-être faut faire un truc comme
c4 et faire vraiment en ligne quoi
envoyer quelque chose d'autre part pour
réussir à [ __ ] un cavalier e 5 est
vraiment foot de partout quoi moi je
regrette ces quatre là quand même parce
que ces gars je menace ces cinq quand
même ouais pour forcer cif et c4 c5
manqué il prépare ce théâtre i l'époque
tom baker badge avec photo yd de ce que
malte en prépa j'aurais pas eu peur
fable jour envoyé quoi je me serais dit
écoute perdu pour perdu je vois pas
pourquoi pas dès 5h vous prend je
comprends qu'elle les prend kg ça c'est
ce que 2,6 g bah écoute on va voir
l'essai en faveur des ibères grave mais
mon mari tient le truc c'est que si
j'arrivais avec l'option s'écarte ça
allait j'aurais pu faire prises avec 7
prises des 5 ou ou feinte yahoo
quelque chose me détente un bain je
pense que à 3 non ma tante avait foutu
un peu plus pur près des quatre
cinquièmes mais bon quand tu es foutu
parfois il faut juste faire envoyer un
truc un peu fou tu m'aimes plus de plus
plus tout le bordel web après on joue
pas contre à royat non plus tu vois
c'est facile à dire on joue contre des
charlots nous là entre charles au hockey
tu t'es dit ok je suis plus foutu de
soissons le bec est complètement nulle
en face
bon là tu te dis pareil le mec est
complètement nul mais enfin il est que
de 1750 tués à 2760 regardent-ils 28-28
ce quelque chose est bon enfin je suis
qu'un nul sauf un pas de chance tu es
nul quand même beaucoup veulent
atteindre respectivement annoncé
préparer nansion tout s'est préparée
comment il respecte j'ai dit respectent
et respectent bien caruana il respecte
bien guéri aussi bizarrement kidon guiry
responsable du mouvement jeudi guy
rivard venir guy machin parce que je le
respecte beaucoup fait unique son seul
problème c'est psychologique mais qu aux
échecs il est vraiment très très très
forte
donc ouais
lady ngo si blizzard fois élu il peut
rentrer qu'il refasse sont importants
rappelons ouais en fait il faudrait
qu'ils prennent à des seconds en nom
chinois pour voir autre chose une autre
vision du jeu l'un est dit qu'ils sont
trop prévisibles
bah ouais il faut que des ragots cinéday
petrov il m'a dit je peux écrire à
l'avancé exactement quelle variante de
la petrov
ils vont jouer et je peux te dire à
l'avancé dans quels pièges ils vont
tomber quoi maïs est là mais il dit
c'est trop simple il dit ça marche
jusqu'à un certain niveau mais il me dit
quand tu joues des cramique des
greenshows amouk tk royal prenne le
temps de d'apprendre ce qui est nouveau
ce niveau là ding mêmes m'a dit le choix
du second dans oui c'était très
soupçonne enfin rédiger le mec à 18 ans
enfin minimes et le pavage
mais c'est bien en fait d'avoir un jeune
je prends son équipe qui travaille que
l'ordi avoir un jeune dans l'est oui
mais le cerveau qui chapeaute un choix
est-ce que cela dit se dit oui si si je
l'entraînais lui peut-être je pourrais
faire quelque chose comme beaucoup mieux
qu'avec cet abruti quoi que je retrouve
en soit encore c'est incroyable vlad
s'ingénie à la fin juin
il a fait autant de points que moi title
tuesday kuachuk vlad est très content
très bonne nouvelle ça fait un long
moment que je lui dis que il ne veut
plus aussi bien qu'avant ça pour les
nuls passif échos de faire autant de
points que kiev quoi il était mort de
rire bon dieu qui l'a arrêté le tournage
parce qu'il a fait il était mort de rire
bad oui mais même ça prouve qu'il est
nul et que tu es bien entraînés quoi en
fait moi ça prouve que je suis ou bien
tu vas y avait été choisi pour répondu
faites vous à tout est relatif pas c'est
génial mais jusqu'où il était mort de
rire mais magique c'est un électrochoc
savait y faire autant de points que toi
c'est un électrochoc
ben c'est marrant je vais pas raconter
un moment donné quand on fait des
joueurs qui étaient jointes 4,50 25 des
voix qu'on ne trouvait pas un exercice
et qui souhaiteraient facilement vous
voyez quoi civile est ce que tu es tu
toi ta troupe évoquée parfois je
trouvais l'âme tempo vraiment quoi sans
rigoler je vais lui non mais oh tu sais
quoi puis d'ici même toi tu trouves
c'est génial charger des talons quand on
sait qu'ils ne sait à peine bouger les
pièces quoi du côlon de la médiocrité
québec parcours c'est génial que ce
mandat 6 était d'ailleurs de l'abruti
total qu'elles s'effondraient si le
dîner de cons voix je viens vous fait
avec cave quoi c'est pas si simple
finances est parti faire du air en
rigole on rigole on m'envoyait mais
aussi j'ai encore plus gros que l'audit
le gym même lui trouve quoi même les
grands maîtres quoi tout le monde peut
vraiment le faire
tennis la ddt le pire c'est qu'en plus
nous l'ont dit ça en rigolant les gens
pensent du second degré mais en fait pas
du tout
finir sur chose ait note un peu plus de
17 secondes à 18 pour un rognon donc
donc attention les mots slip les machins
maintient mot anglais il n'y a pas le
droit thomas ou skiffs qu'ici pour la
fin mais pas d'armé en france a dû
suspendre souris tu vois je suis pas je
pense erreur de souris ou sleeps très
bien même bull est en fait un jeu de
cartes où je vois une cartouche je joue
en cartouche mais c'est chaud enfin
hélas enfants dès six bons le faire
bouffer parce que tu veux pas défendre
kg soit une fourchette avril à bouger au
pied mais je savais pas si bédié de
partir parce que tu laisses lacaune
ceolin arc il m'inquiétait un peu
inquiet il sa nature parents face à face
à face à un prix trouve du jeu car c'est
pas grave on qui est dominé dans mon
truc mais qu'après c'est bien joué pas
mal pour se tenir jusqu'à value 8 g 5 kg
7 pourra venir sur les toits on trouve
provoque de g5
on se faufile ibot il faut tomates et 1
il propose le matin même alors même pas
loin bref on enfin pas loin mais de
l'autre côté c'est chaud tagammou gauche
tongien et méprisent été saisi par huit
ans ouais mais bon des huit projets car
elle va faire des huit s'échauffent ah
ben là c'est chaud c'est chaud
à ce jour deux parties qui mènera
d'autres permis de se marrer souvent
bits
je suis très énervé remprend qu'avaient
les 5 et 6 4
ouais c'est bien joué prise à froid
[Musique]
encore bon encore non c'est non c'est
non mais nous on aurait ramené même
maintenant qu'en fin de ce salon de
refermer
pas si sûr et bien il va quelques
débiteur n'est mentionné bien sorti
parce que ouais c'était chaud nauroy
montel qui ont des monts femmes limite
je suis pas sûr que nous on fasse un
avec aussi peu de temps sur la pendule
quand on agit en disgrâce ou quoi ouais
mais je penserai gamme sacrément nul
second barrage où c'est beaucoup tu peux
plus tomber
ouais mais que 30 minutes pour chaque
fois on regarde comment à renier ni
galère mais il prend quand il met au
baril a gagné leur pari la galére quand
même failli il a mis trente coups à
gagner non serait pris une fourchette de
mère n'aurait perdu enfin le manager il
faut le savoir quoi faire un faut être
objectif à 24 mai sarre union ii 5 jeux
à 4 depuis le début mai a du coup elle
calerait qui joue pas ça fait trop de
cas run tu passerais perçoit elle joue
pas là petrov pour après dire c'est un
handicap quand même quand tu joues un
match aller que tout cas ton répertoire
dans blitz ok mais je pense c'est pas
bête en avant un double répertoire
parties lentes bits soit toi t'en double
répertoire ou pas
je sais pas je suis fan en lituanie
choix mais pas très part et je dirai
quand je serai dérape leaders régionaux
ça va et je suis rarement des arts très
fort terra mondiale jamais soyons clairs
il ya parfois les encore c'est la
rigueur y avait le truc alors c'est quoi
on va dire mais bon beaucoup trop long
ah oui c'est vrai qu'il y avait 18 ronde
terrifie créatif invoquée c'est
n'importe quoi mais bon
mais mais à part ces deux tournois là je
veux pas vendre à pitre farc
ok tu peut-être aix-en-provence main par
ci par là mais même en fait c'est à dire
que tu auras une ou deux rondes
décisives qui ont des foires en maître
mais là je t'en fais pas de mec me
frappe c'est ça en fait les rapides que
ces bateaux des gens moins fort que toi
pendant des cas c est ok voilà donc t'as
pas besoin de faire c'est un double à
partir ou quoi après s'il ya vraiment
des circuits où je joue souvent contre
les meilleurs l'élite de la nation quoi
l'avant je tais tu aurais besoin qu'on
du coup une femme on a envie de balançan
hachey cela on a envie de se préparer du
cavalier f5 3,6 pourquoi pas mais sur ce
qui peut stocker chez toi je te ferai
car les f-5 tempo ouais mais je te diras
à toi ajouté mme cau j'aurais eu plus de
carrière en fait j'aurais fait la même
chose mais plus vite sur yo ké des
maires de soi enfin fait ta vie quoi
faire je sais pas faire je joue quoi
enfin moi je vais sacrifier tu vois ce
que je veux dire non mais c'est sûr
qu'il veut faire toi je sais pas moi je
suis sur le set sur quelque chose
surtout
on est partout où je vais peut-être
remettre un petit lien fab de partage
parce que faut que ça partage
vas-y sur le chat et je vais faire un
petit os sur la chaîne mistry puisque tu
as je commence un peu à souffler avec
l'écran là je commence à habiter avant
sous de la mousse et up et refuse je
commence un peu à respirer tu as et une
fois si tu m'entendais pas ou quoi c'est
que enfin vous pouvez les traits de 50
euros notre envie est sûre je m'habille
savez la hauteur du portable genève je
peux aller des cours par tous ces chocs
je remets un peu nos visages mais bon je
fais un bon set up on peut voir les
visages des joueurs on peut remettre nos
visages tout va bien gérant des amateurs
mais on se bat nos armes ben comme aux
échecs il est complètement nul mais on
fait ce qu'on peut pas donc là bien sûr
le plancher 4 n'est pas en prison
s'il faut prendre en compte les
principes six échecs et on est bien mais
qu'est ce qu'être tombait donc et 6 des
normes et ouais surtout ils souffrent
encore le petit feu bientôt des trois
îles se commence à s'en prendre aussi à
l'ale dame un peu même si tu peux jouer
que ces quatre jours il ya pas longtemps
j'ai vu une partie 2 2 je vais préparer
pour la chaîne pour des master class je
fais pas encore jetés par une partie de
fisher il fait ça et maintenant des cinq
plus prudent qu'il ramène sa tour à une
attaque à l dame fatigue ou les deux les
deux l1 peut pas on a fait ce matin
aussi quoi c'est une hernie zoologique
ouais toujours ce qui était une de ses
marques de fabrique
du couvre feu 3 menace de devoir à tous
pour bien
mais là faut la question c'est qu'un
jour on fait des cinq faut trouver
comment voyez la femme à chaque fois je
me sens un peu cette physionomie d'un
senior on collait pas j'adore la passion
des rognons très vite un moment non
c'est un petit buffet caruana joue pas
son répertoire aussi un fab ce mois il
m'impressionne encense la caravane a pas
dans le sens sur wii domine le match ou
quoi mais dans le sens où il joue pas à
ces ouvertures dans le d4 d5 de thaler
l'alleud londres ça lui a clairement
coûté 1 l'ouverture est quand même il
revient chez 4ad russie va te faire
damas trois à faire j'ai quatre en deux
fois 20 h 30 sam un truc c'est que
nature damas trois femmes avec les noirs
et ton attaque elle va battre de l aile
rapidement quoi et j'ai pour vivre
j'adore je voulais pas changer d'un
blessé l'autre en j'imite mais peut-être
que j'ai 4 mais à foot et 4 dames à 5
aussi ouais enfin j'ai 4 ans premier
j'aime bien beaucoup ce coup tu coules
cavaliers tu t'en prends un peu h5
est-ce que foulbé un des clous je pense
quoi qu'on veuille prendre le califat en
fait même si on a une structure bien sûr
la plongée va plutôt profité aux blancs
donc c'est pas tellement l'idée mais
c'est plutôt paralysé tu places mieux
ton foot attaqué poste 5
j'ai bien qu'ici sur place et le cavaly
g8 fab way puis tu presses des cas non
ce peuple là bas
tout est possible tout est possible
c'est bien la note est ce qu'on peut
juin b4 enfin en venant en d2 peut-être
avant les cas c'est ce que je skie pour
mettre la pression sur des quatre en
fait en s'en prenant aux pions c3 des
pieds après ce qu'on fait de dessins ça
ressemble à un genre d'espagnol un fab
c'est un peu ton ouverture et fétiche
bien surtout qu'il eut à 6 des cinq
cantons de vaud structures ont bien
commencé partout reprend des deux paras
temps il n'ya pas des quatre qui tombe
là je m'étonne qu'ils arrivent ok peut
s'inquiéter mais je pensais de l'idée
d'orient qui donne des quatre uniques et
ouvrir c'est un peu à double tranchant
après un arrêt totalement mais peut-être
qu'il n'avait pas atteint la tension au
centre et celui de pêcher en eaux
troubles
après c'est un bon c'est un très bon
pêcheur on nous trouve la presse
non mais se précipite pas à faire de
cinq échecs sommes heureuses qui veut
organiser 50 ans du coup on ne peut pas
vraiment faire dans le massachusetts
haut rhin si on retire auquel on la
pensait que les prendre tu veux dire
prendre des 4b 5b y aura peut-être des
détroits après as tu prend 1,8 peux-tu
preuve de prudence en mai tu crois que
tu reprends du roi maintenant je dois
gérer aisément être non non non non non
moi je vais faire des trois pour libérer
le fou est pas j'espère que le four
revient dans d'étroits sûrement et
j'aimais pas trop le foot b6 et qui
reste un peu notre jeu mais peut-être
tara quart des saints je suis ok il
s'enlève bons coups prophylactique est
ce qu'on fait un cavalier 2 kiev 4 jours
à consacrer si on a intéressé 4 mieux
manger parce que jusque là pour le coup
gagné un petit tempo et il peut prendre
des six venir un f5 mais voué à les
cases noires mais bon c'est un pion
vraiment nombreux à demander si ce n'est
qu'il faut pas qu'on se retrouve tous
ses 5 et b4 peut-être est faux c'est
celle d'un prend les quatre éléments qui
avaient carrément f54 avec tempo ou
quirion c'est kader aussi possible comme
c'est un peu d'autres il s'en prend aux
femmes non état du cavalier h 4 kg si ce
qui peut arriver suivant il est re mieux
que la remet en jeu le rend si on
m'envoie du vieux 5
après si on comprend qu'ils aient agi
car tu forces qui aura lieu cet effort à
l'e3 en question et toi tu peux pas mais
bon ça va rien de temps le temps donne
des trains ou peut-être un fou ces 4 dan
ait eus pen y en a quatre il faut 6 4 6
3 mais là peut-être un accueil j'ai ici
ce prix zeddam prend et il va retracer
leur fou la batterie dans le bon sens
ouais bon on n'a pas nous sommes tous
les quatre peut-être claquer une kalach
un dame s'est vite food étroite reprend
détroit et peut-être fou destin non mais
t'as pas vrai parce que tout doit être
prêt faire mater que des 5 es tu vas
faire un tour pranger 3 et france 5
non mais auquel à la qualité elle fait
mal hein ouais mais pas encore bien sûr
non non en longues oui mais en blitz on
sait pas encore peut-être en vient aux
un vêtement un allié loyal est venu il a
44 secondes c'est bien à ça pour faire
cette phase technique quidam g6
ok elle a ses tours 8
les vannes qui prend le dessus en ce
qu'ils étaient menés 1 0 3 88 3
victoires de suite c'est qu'au tennis on
dit que quand tu marques trois pointes
un momentum frappe en est fier c'était
des juges tu commences à faire mal à
l'adversaire dans la tête quoi tu sais
ton bon bon
il est retourné au quatrain finalement
pourquoi pas et mon élan sont les
premiers à prendre le centre avec des
cinq fab
voilà bien souvent fait une bonne job et
rate son centre et ericka mais tu peux
le faire quand les blancs juste et 3
parce que tu as eu cinq faible d'un côté
fait part attaqué par trois compagnies
mettent à contre attaque sur détroit
c'est une curieuse c2c moins de bonnes
idées quand tu arrives à s'en prendre
tête avec vous et 5 directement puis en
d3 1 jordan 17 tours d81 c'est ça ouais
t'as il ne faut prendre trois jours ce
genre de pression que j'aime pas du tout
avec les blancs mais en fait
objectivement ça il ya des joueurs qui
descend beaucoup mieux il a joué c'est
une sorte d'activité et des fautes fait
kg 5 damage 5 et des docks a lieu quatre
pas des cases et tout comme sa ferme et
en fait le défaut de structure ce pion
détroit m'énerve trop là en train de
faire est en train de remettre
accueillant 1 4 non mais je t'avais pas
ils commencent à ce jour normal tôt mais
juste je la sens tellement pas juste pas
envie de jouer mais ça c'est mon goût
à bas les goûts sa soeur ça se discute
pas fabien les goûts et les couleurs
il faut ensuite solide quoi bret alors
dame f3 ou trois je ferais bien mais ça
furiani de quatre femmes dont elle par
d'autres étaient peut-être tu auras des
huit noms développe toutes les pièces un
fab passe un truc que tu fais souvent
dans des parties déjà remarquer tu
développes des pièces ses 107 bien c'est
à toutes les pièces active après le truc
c'est que des fautes à l'action qui
commence mais ok tu dois prendre part
c'est ton truc je veux d'avoir développé
mais si tu peux maintenant je serai bien
fou j'ai ici savent 5 avec énormément
non monsieur oui c'est un truc que je
déteste en fait quand je vois les
plantes aux jeux vidéo au japon avec
cinq jeux sans trois rangées 10 et 3
faible que je comprends pas ce que je
fais je suis au ps mais c'est un tout
opportuniste un peu accablant que tu
sois tu joues actifs si tu peux sauter
sur une pièce tu viens le foot y reçoit
des grenats ne sais pas mais je me sens
à l'aise je suis pas qu'ils se
sentiraient pas je me tais tu fasses 4,5
tu vois c'est des trucs comme ça que
vous cherchez
l'as far est quand même très
opportuniste faut être dans l'esprit à
fait dans l'esprit des charges saillie
cham
il avait toujours assez bien que mais du
coup si tu joues bien avec les blancs
c'est hyper chiant parce qu'avec les
noirs tard on était bien et si
objectivement pas vraiment bien tu peux
péter un câble non je pense équilibré
mais qu'avec les blancs je pensais plus
dur à jouer côté blanc côté là je pense
les rares côté blanco plus cher parce
que tu as eu des 300 trip avant c'était
des choses comme ça donc rares médecins
qui attendait simplement donné bon
service et saint georges mais donc aussi
nous fait mieux préparés c'est ici on
voit ça mais bon faut pas se paniquer
des 600 kg vite fait qu'ils aient tout
couvrir la justice au pied et peut-être
faire fouilles 6 quai saint caprais ou
faux âge 7 sûrement découvre bien mais
aulas active et clément jay souvient il
avec le d4 et un truc important à fond
sur ces 6 et caïds et 6 suprendre de
passe et ce qui saute ça tournait
toujours que le peuple ce cavalier seul
ça arrive ça sentait pas le nom non plus
que le nom ce qui pouvait pas faire
[ __ ] injustice et sonos peut-être
toujours vous serez option prend quel
point m6 ok je sais pas enfin nous et
tout comme ça qu'il faut arriver à être
pas pour tout de suite
bref on insiste encore points 4 passes
et défendent pas les cartes blanches là
c'est mort lâche il faut aussi de faire
des pronostics
est ce que ça marche mais j'arrive
sacrifier quoi perdre et tout voir les
jeunes matt version soir par dans as
troyak lecavalier quand même ça laisse
un petit répit quoi
après peut-être de courte durée 1 2
contre lui affirmant toujours est
quasiment faible
ah ben tu as envie de faire des villes
mais bon ok ça va tu pars je suis fier
c'est que tu as passé même question
belote
j'hésite pas trop j'y vais demain la
main joue et il a calculé il va jouer
quelqu'un de moins de 1000 à des
compensations
ouais surtout que sur pu en prendre à me
prends des cats et peut-être fou et
trois dames prend 1,4 faut prendre v6
double attaque mais peut-être tu dois
pas prendre tout sûr que comprendra
quatre jours amènent un caïd des dessins
oui oui on est très très probablement
meilleur tu n'as même pas mine de plomb
de moins mais bon il va te jouer le pion
isolé mais bon avec quatre ans je t'aime
c'était très peur après ça les durs à
concrétiser un parce que ils nous ont
montré à ce niveau la fable ça défend
tellement bien à rennes les bains ouais
c'est c'est hallucinant sap est si
simple que ça de faire parler les cases
blanches
il est peut-être même est ce qu'il va
être gourmand les prendre à coeur
évidemment par un peu too much fab
joachim bd qui avait payé 5 j'aimais
beaucoup ton coup peut-être un jour tu
feras du f 5 un relief 6 tu as études et
après tu remets le cavalier e en d5 toi
tu tu reviens calme a été un peu tes
cases blanches et tu tournes non j'ai
beaucoup appris je peux commencer par f5
aussi peut-être mais attention aux 5
il ya trois ilets une direction toute
tracée vers au 5 mai mais bon ça sent
fort des fans qu'on sait sur un an un
autre tu peux peut-être mettre le
cavalier eux ont des cinq ans ces cas là
comme ça tu gardes tu fais f5 fou bouge
cavalia ud5 et peut-être s'il va faire
vous prend à 3 tu donneras complètement
les deux fous et tu viendrais avec les
cavaliers c'est de colmater le centre ou
qu'il a fait du kung fu trois dames e k
s'il veut prendre b2 mais juste devant
nitoo rhodiens ben je t'assure dam des
quatre fautes 3 dames b4 peut-être
femmes 1
ouais c'est pas bête il a caché pendant
un moment et il allait prendre l'option
fab
donc ceux qui essaient de te donne trois
quatre fois qu'on réussise de francs 16
heures à la pointe
fable c'est chaud fab le charognard à
plus d'une vie jeudi le chat parce que
s'il avait le fameux tee shirt avec le
chablais ce sont des gens bien étrange
non
wynau be well son style vestimentaire il
ya là il a la classe quoi bon alors
donne paris protège le fouet au québec
ginsig ouais bon logique bravo à ces
jeunes gens tout son corps garden et
bien culture de 4 donc pas besoin de
s'acharner à gagner de plus isolé dans
cinq ans coup il ya déjà plein et après
évidemment savoir les lignes pour les
fous comme dirait mur face - si tu tiens
tu gagnes tu joues plus là nul après si
tu m'aimes et là on peut même faire f5
là et rendre le pion ouais si tôt non
mais pas pas forcément maintenant mais
bon le petit monde à moi j'aurais fait
mais parce que je ne veux pas me faire
attaquer ça ne m'intéresse pas mais gère
le fait d'avoir gagné un pion ça te
permet d'avoir l'option de le rendre
mais bon c'est trois
vous ces trois ça fait part à mon avis
400 chansons puisées à 24 secondes à
rognan il va quand même falloir défendre
notre combat tactique des machins morin
je n'ai pas bien concret pour l'instant
mais je te ramène tes pierce avec les
blancs les tournus tour à 3 de mach 1 mg
kg 3 il faut vous racketter la whey mais
qui a valu aux trois peut-être f5
ah ouais j'suis d'accord en date est
objectivement c'est rien c'est
visuellement que ça fait peur c'est pas
mal mon fabing parce que tour cn à temps
de prendre le 4 et après elle 5 n'a plus
de place pour le foot la 3f 5 tu as plus
de casse pour le foot c'était obligé de
retourner en b1 ce qui est triste qu
après je pu ramener la tour rail joue
bien femmes aronian dans cette partie
c'est beau ce qui fait non mais je joue
bien je joue bien pendant tout le match
mais là c'est vivre ces moments se
tourne elle en fait concrètement ça
tournait pas encore trop tôt à iran le
pion un an et celui des 4 et/ou ouais
mais c'est bien ça c'est magnifique non
tu ne dois pas prendre et n avait
sûrement pour d'autres et d'amérique a
très bien la finale c'est peut-être rien
pour cette même un peu mieux pour les
blancs mais très efficace c'est pas bien
joué en fait puisque foulée si ce jour
arrive à clous et j'aime pas ce que la
jeunesse des clous au passage ils
veulent porter un habit toutefois bombe
à 300 m il est revenu avec des blancs et
les revivre pas tout le temps la paire
de fou dans une position avec le centre
est ouvert à des collabos centre où
l'armée combat sans abri au stage un peu
il y en a qui étaient présents fabien
tête qui sont présents mais c'est pas
fait il a doublé les pions sur le roi du
coup le 3 contre 2 à l'aller le droit et
pas forcément facile à faire passer va
essayer de défendre d'autres b3 dont
qu'il fasse un peu mieux
enfin je suis très très heureux de cette
partie tours a trois enfants vient de le
farm montauroux 3 il s'est bien gardé
développeurs faux g4 qui est contre eux
il va vite en rognant il va mettre la
torah 4 favre garde ou en d4
quelque part c'est quand même des sacrés
équilibristes c'est impressionnant femme
je vois que regardait donc je peux tu
regardes et tu as j'étais une équipe je
reviendrai je vois pas les choses comme
ouais bah écoute fait pour le moment ça
se bat les van kessel échange d'un fou
mais c'est peut-être il est peut-être en
train de craquer ya la tour qui arrive
sur la 6e il ya tous les pions ya tous
les pions qui sont en prise
il va y avoir du cahier pour en f3 tu
tournes déduite
ça va tenir sa fab constat d'entretien
ou pas bah comme en sélection
bien que le défi est tombé 5 et
peut-être du hasch cicero h5 comment il
peut changer sans exception 4 c'est bien
joué et je compte 64 mo j'écarte échec
mais sait il va être changé philidor on
veut montrer autant prefab fantastiques
magnifiques et là même la défense
passive marche c'est un pion g ouais je
pense que là nul à lui mérité sur cette
partie face c'était vraiment une belle
partie pas rester fantastique assez du
beau jeu femme jeu parce que j'en pense
dans le chatt bon mais là c'est du très
haut niveau qu'on est en train de voir
fable dans ce match oui donc ça joue
bien franchement et ses coutures acquise
et cette petite pause quand même qui
repart pas tout de suite il est tu as
ils méritent pas une seconde de risque
de l'avoir dit lampes et futurs pas tu
veux téléphone qui va boire un peu de
lait dans sa dans sa gamelle qu'enfin il
revient enfin il je suis un chat enfin
jp
devis est arrivé du polisson sur la
caméra ça boit un petit peu et continuer
à voir les deux joueurs paraissent
épuisé mais en fait non pas du tout
partie interrompue partie interrompue
alors les censures donc trois mois et
demi un tour tous de mêlée vonn qui
monte des grosses capacités en défense
de ressources qui compte ce n'est plus
trop de temps il joue vite
ouais ça va être important pour le
impuissant il boit il boit il s'alimente
caruana qui s'alimente pas forcément
énormément on le voit pas s'alimenter
attention à la fringale ou pouvoir faut
manger du sucre 5 fruits et légumes
fabien sait que les bananes
pourquoi le mode de consommation des
bananes très important donc monsieur
payen 06 min franchement se régale même
l'annuler bella est mais bon c'est pas
c'est pas les échecs classique où tu te
fais chier pendant six heures font
reconnaître femme quand même mieux
c'est beaucoup mieux ah bon on peut pas
le dire avant on peut le dire à toutes
formes dans l'ue toujours en fait ça et
on a tout fait pas changer les choses on
a beau dire que mon du monde est
d'accord mais quand tout le monde
d'accord
les joueurs sont alors les audiences
sont d'accord mais en réalisateur sont
d'accord
les joueurs sont d'accord ils mai
dernier à tort qu'ils sont d'accord
qu'il fasse quoi bon vieux débat c'est
lé biais peut-être plus grand à prendre
si tu fais payer 9 jours d'hôtel tu vois
il ya peut-être des raisons aussi
peut-être des choses sont plus
intéressantes de garder le format qui
existe aujourd'hui est une question
finalement fab simplement qui
l'enserrent de on voit que ça marche
mais bon y'a des gens qui aiment bien le
jeu tu dis pas que mon avis mais mais
généralement c'est pas les gens qui
décident des gens qui aiment bien le jeu
tu as des gens qui décident c'est plutôt
les gens ne la rend bien l'argent des
gens qui aiment bien le jeu généralement
c'est un peu des connards qui commande
d'être battue alors les tenir
c'est céder à la russie qui font des
vidéos pour pas grand chose sur la fin
j'en connais deux sera attention il y en
a un qui est plus conclut autres mais je
dirai pas lequel
y'en a vraiment il est au dessus tu vois
tu te sens tu connais tu vois quand tu
lui parles cuisson qui tire vers le bas
tu sens que je peux l'aider mais qu'ils
ont commencé cgt avant le fin de 25 20
25 30 tu vois tu as tu sentais tu vas à
qui personne peut tout de suite tête
sous l'eau tout être saoul au fcc
l'équivalent du cac et le mec a
complètement chuté il n'en peut plus
quand il y est j arrête de jouer je fus
il aime le jeu mais mon lift est ce
qu'on peut envoyer six la fable iii et
fils tout reprend m6 allait boom
ok mais le moment quelques avanies un
truc pour pèse pas grave
au nom de comment on fait pour aller
voir caruana carlson à londres il faut
acheter des billets mais ils sont pas
encore en vente
malheureusement mais sur quoi cette
[ __ ] tu le revends après mais je sais
pas mais sans voix et 6 la femme enfin
désolé qua non mais je m'excuse mais tu
fais f6 le mec te bouffer avec le foutu
bouffon site de merde
il prend tu as la dame aurait faisait
cap des 50 aux aveux mais il aurait
voulu matin dans les coulisses et c'est
ok c'est roland enfin pas l'envoyer tout
de suite pas perdre de temps non ok il
veut faire quoi dams et devait changer
pouvoir accès syndicat libre des six
attentats est située g6 feu dame
français de ces salles après 2,6 j'aime
bien les noirs un fab
j'ai bien puisque le 4 faible je te
prends un truc d'hommes c4 une tour c4
ces deux là tu as qu elle m'a repoussé
fermement que juste tours fc est roi et
suite ça suffit à 1 à presque même les
bonnes aronian où je suis même pas sûr
ccir donc il ya des cinq cas il ya
d'armes français de aussi fait à 20 qui
restent
ça sera toujours mais par des cinq jours
tout on prend toujours la gagne ce qui
est fou qui a dans ces cinq de pouvoir
liquider cette fois ci viennent tout mon
truc d'érosion bon 3,3 crépon pays
tout restera bon repas chauds sont
offerts par wife's est aussi un que
j'aurais pas fait mais qui n'a bougé
envisagé étant j'éviterai maintenant
quoi de plus c'est clément sait plus
très bien
bon bah il est l'heure de dessin tu veux
pas faire dame ces quatre mêmes fables
tu vas carrière m'entraîner pour
sûrement dans lequel j'aime bien ton oui
bon tu peux commencer comme ça aussi un
tueur damev deux des trois jeunes hommes
et dames 6 4 c'est pas mal mais mesdames
ces cartes est moins fort manque a fait
le tour ans et 8 ça peut faire sourire
on va b 3 ok mais là cela me prend à 4
quand même et des cinq peut-être aussi
un handicap cinq temps ont besoin tu as
trop envie de faire ton fossati peut pas
rester comme ça tout ça lui fait plaisir
at on fout quoi voilà mais peut-être
champion prend même et sur food & cie
sur un fou aux quatre matches donne
vraiment belle mais d'après 5,6 te fais
peut-être des six comprend 2 5 6 me achi
s'est défendue par l'adam fin maintenant
je prends des cinq taupes en souffrent
décès si je prends des bronches et peut
porter leur bon sens fait saddam air
deviennent fous de cette faille a trouvé
cette 1ère et je vois
c'est tendu s'est tendu mais je pense
aux plans dessins que pour le prendre un
de façon non enfin de tout prendre seul
qui peut faire
j'ai pas mon femmes j'en sais rien
ok super thématiques comme ça marche pas
ça marche quoi pas de chance florian qui
est un petit peu préoccupé du niveau de
decarone avant le match en novembre
alors non on ne s'en va pas préoccupé
déjà c'est d'autres cadence s'est pas il
est déjà pas si mal et c'est notre
cadence fin j'aurais très préoccupé s'il
devait jouer le match en rapide ou en
blitz contre car le sel voilà c'est zéro
chance et leur et zéro chance mais bon
de toute façon
karlsson super favorite me promener
complètement famille il ajouta ghislain
score positif en lente et même si à 6,6
ce qui est déjà un bon score pour que
rona rapides sont surtout ce qui va lui
arriver quoi donc
c'est un exploit ce qui rend dingue et
mieux match après en ce que 41 peut
penser c'est que s'il arrive en rapide
ne sera quand même content et plus le
match dur c'est simple cette théorie la
cua matches par équipe c'était bon on
l'entend peu triste très bonne idée mais
décréter des rapides alors qu'arsène
accepter le rapide bien que je la
dernière à cleveland pas en me disant ok
j'ai quatre chances en quatre parties
voiturier puisqu'on sida plus forts les
plus forts mais joue quelques particules
non mais plus risquées risque caruana
est content s'ils arrivent à 6 600 l'an
finalement dans le sens où je pense
qu'ils n'ont pas longtemps dans l'absolu
tu es content si ces pages plats du
monde que tu dis sur l'année tu avais
tout soit à 103 6 malaisiens tenir
compte en banque ou myspace crise que
finalement ces chances de perdre avant
le solaire c'est parce que finalement il
n'a pas plus de chance de gagner en
rapide en quatre parties que de gagner
en longtemps 12 skill également un fort
relent tôt si enfin il est moins fort
partout ne changera pas bon rempart veux
toi je prédis papillon par l'équipe en
fait c'est rama sall est pas du tout bas
il était il est passé à deux doigts de
l'emporter 1 voilà dans toutes ces
discussions ce que je sais pas mais mon
feeling modique
je vous moquez pas de zéro chance pour
ce commet mon fils il m'a dit si tu
arrives banques évidemment si tu arrives
à 5,5
par exemple il a de meilleures chances
en de gagner sur les deux dernières en
lente oui mais jamal si on part du début
où il ya douze partis ou de toute façon
les gammes beaucoup de choses de se
faire des chansons lentes
qu'est ce que t'es pas content d'avoir
tu as si on me demandait si tu avais le
choix cela maintenant tu as aujourd'hui
genre en alu les douze parties de vue
que les quatre ans rapide je pense qu'il
a plus de chances que l'autre soit dans
un mauvais jour où je sais pas une gamme
notre truc comme ça pas de 60 jamais à
l'abri dans un match mais tu peux tomber
malade tu peux battre en forme dire des
choses même personne consorts à
l'habitude même des matchs il a pas de
toi tu en super forme est là c'est assez
beau femme parce qu'il joue pour surtout
quand elle si tu veux faire dame prend
1,6 et sur d'armes premiers froids il
veut jouer le père pète d'am-dam rang et
fit ces dames dans mes fils d'un mafieux
carpet oui non mais bon tu aies jamais
le rythme est bon le truc c'est que les
échecs ses douze partis ces 21 jours
vingt dix trains p tu vois ce que je
veux dire je ne sais pas vendre l'époque
enfin les matches je pense juste pas de
bêtises mais le carport casse-toi très
différente en 84 il avec un certain
nombre de jours de repos qui décidez de
prendre ou pas suivant en france ça se
passe à syrte avait perdu si tu avais un
coup de main entre cantons à travailler
ok il y avait levé des vraies raisons
mais c'était pas des robots tout le
temps mais mon père je vis ici à des
historiens dans le tchat
dites nous où des historiennes ou
d'histoire c'est pas bon mais il défend
pas mal aronian cette position quand
même puisque c'était pas ça reste pas
évident mais il trouve des petites
ressources des petites idées live jouer
avec g5 maintenant le fond h6 pas mal
placé femme un faux signal et même île à
l'autre une sorte de 7 pour tenir la
position
bon après avec les noirs qui va s y
tient un des trois bien senti
alors quoi pour ces trois sont venus et
ils vont faire gaffe de ne pas lâcher
complètement la vie des moines avant que
ça peut être dangereux peut se retourner
contre eux contre fabiano fab modèle
abraham
nice n avoir pas besoin non mais là faut
qu'il faut absolument qu'ils gagnent
alors est ce que on peut jouer un truc
comme damache d'alger 2 j'aime bien donc
les gens attendaient toujours cloué au
lit il peut faire foi f3 quoique ya pas
de menace là c'est chaud fab
il s'infiltre mais mayroy je croyais
couffin c'est pas mal ça progresse et
c'est que si sa plume à quatre ans et
trois tapis très amicale il peut quand
même à résister de g5 femme qui
contraint regarde regard hagard il passe
par bessin regarde là alors qu'elle
regarde le fourbe gymnase des cinq
regarde le fourbe la tête du feu dame
bessac menacé d'un 8 matin ça incroyable
incroyable incroyable quel numéro
d'équilibriste de l'even relatives à la
tour en fait voilà tu peux sortir les
cracheurs de feu taza tout le monde si
elle a des peut-être le tour sa chance
tourne dans la notion d'art incroyable
magnifique fantastique le setup défensif
ça ça a semblé ne pas tenir
quelle victoire et je pense que c'est un
premier vrai tournant dans le match
c'est à dire qu'ils ont été les bonnes
un peu au dessus mais caruana qui
pouvait coller et là on tu vois ça à
dirt 3 et demi deux ans et demi c'est
pas comme un ennemi quatre et demi pas
là c'est pas pareil mais qui comprend
bien la dynamique des matches face
depuis steam a expliqué à budapest
j'ai maintenant je comprends que ma
servante je vis des bons quatre ennemis
nos ennemis bon enfin on s'en fout dans
les yeux le truc c'est que voilà tu joue
pas pareil tu as plus la pression c'est
pas la même chose
parmi les forts efforts et en plus ça
m'inquiète pour fabiano dans l'oeil
minutes si on n'était pas sur des
garanties coffret les vols en un plus un
jardin sauf qu'on a un élément de
réponse ici une femme
fable c'est chaud bon ok on a encore à
londres à peu près la même valeur mais
bon au moins il n'a pas fléchi 3g 2
c'est tendu s'est tendu je remets un
lien femmes vers si les gens veulent
nous aider avec les médias sociaux pour
partager les élus nous ont dit qu'ils
sont là femmes qui skient nuit tellement
dommage que les bonnes n'est pas gagner
les candidats m et l'habilité très loin
tu vois il a faim menace est de gagner
en fait la fille dernier non je sais
plus menarini n'y a pas de mélanges qui
souffrent à totalement cesser de fumer
c'est lui et il s'est même perdant
contre gries ku pourquoi les blancs pas
le sdk pour enfin les cavaliers je pense
qu'ils avaient toujours du cavaliere 4
pour sortir attaque
ma terreur qui lui dit qu'il est nouveau
ici
salut ma terreur qui ce qu'il mouille
c'est lui en fait donc du coup la menace
est de se qualifier si on avait pris le
le candidat à l'ancienne tu vois vous et
je prends le joueur le moins fort pour
me défier ouais mais du coup je promets
qu'ils étaient pas au candidat maxime en
fait bon tu me prends nous pensons
souvent vite ce crime a déjà fait nul
contre moi un très dangereux très
dangereux joueurs de grubb je pense ça
fera un gros match je le défie mais du
coup je peux refuser
bon ben je pense que le résultat est
courue d'avancé mais que beaucoup moins
fort que moi j'ai déjà pas propres à
participer à cette mascarade que sont
les candidats et ce n'est pas pour jouer
contre un adversaire du même acabit
ouais ça ça m'intéressera d'ailleurs il
a l'air en forme
il a fait quoi aujourd'hui
il atténue la pompe tizi delà mais ouais
il a gagné la première la source à chris
de damas près d'agde une belle finale
devant maxime les mamans et mamies en
forme aussi femmes
il a beau être que tu fais tu n'as pas
j'ai jamais douté de son talent ça c'est
pas le problème mais je suis étonné
parce que je pensais qu'ils visitaient
ultra motivés pour les candidats c'est
un peu la chance de sa vie
parce que ma mais il est un peu moins
jeunes générations précédemment là je
crois une amende allant de moins mais la
33 ans 34 ans est ok bon aux échecs en
général ses meilleures années c'est
plutôt 25 35 ont adhéré et je pense
c'est vrai qu'il a tout donné pour les
candidats avec de hockey de rater enfin
dehors il n'a pas raté suffisamment bon
c'est pas que pour se qualifier il
allait se faire un petit coup de mou
mais en fait moi je prends encore très
en forme pour appuyer le des prépas et
là des truffes les mettre en mieux en
fait c'est un genre que j'aime bien et
j'aime bien comme il joue je pense qu'il
peut se qualifier au prochain candidat
par le vélo d'ailleurs puisque caronna
sera qualifié d'office ou karl scène
suivant le résultat du match il restera
deux places à prendre aux lots et 2008
pas trop rires c'est sûr c'est la
moyenne sur 2 ans donc on démarre bien
maintenant enfin après difficile de te
rattraper un surtout à mesure nous
entraînons mais les joueurs qui étaient
bien classé au début de sa femme s'était
qui s'était cramique mais grammy qui
l'emmenait en digital et maxime mes
toiles aux stones et où il ya de cette
année de cette année sur le sénat donc
cette année tu t'attaques à roanne
acquise face on sera qualifiés donc lui
compte pas entre guillemets ou karl
scène l'un ou l'autre mais les deux
contres ont pas donc après dans ce qui
était bien classé depuis le début de
l'année puisque les moyennes elle compte
depuis depuis janvier là où depuis mars
permet peu importe mais t'avais maxime
et maxime il en chute libre
il va avoir beaucoup de mal à remonter
après avoir faut qu'ils finissent
viennent là bon c'est sûr que l'auto
raconte malela 0,5 sur trois c'est dur
mais bon on va attendre le milieu on
l'avait vu à l'ailé guiry les machins
qui sont en train de monter en ce moment
c'est enfin l'été
mais ils commencent de loin n'ont fait
même si les rattrape mamés genre fin de
l'année il aura quand même eu vingt dix
points de moins
et tu vas devoir dû prendre 20.30 même
si les deux demandes elle en fait je
sais pas mais c'est pas mal ce encaissé
trois quarts 20 mai j'étais tenté de
penser à vous prendre des cinq supports
se prend des échanges aux cavaliers tout
cas et contre tout le club des cinq donc
c'est moi une option mais il joue plus
même initiative en fait car alain
hamonet il faut absolument qu'il la
gagne ça la femme a déjà fait qu'ils
adorent ce que j'avais dit donc ne pas
trop lui porter la poisse veillée
leveaux lui qui viennent des parties il
a deux à trois points de retard c'est
beaucoup
oui il ya ding aussi infâme et shionogi
dans le chatt ya ding qu'on oublie
qu'ils aussi dans les gros lots mais mam
être digne tu vas y à deux places n ya
pas qu une place au vélo
donc même si dit alors qu'on écoute 2700
live en même temps c'est important on
parle d'échec alors du coup de carlson
bon il à 28,48 irons tous à un moment tu
on se bâtit l'enseignement un mondial
combien de temps encore le très bon car
on a quand même battu de 22 1 mam et 28
06 lordon classé numéro 1 viennent d'une
quatrième avec 27 97
et après tu as un méga tout en fait guy
à 27,86 en 27 20 g nique à 25,19 n'a
qu'à 27 77 cardiaque 1913 et maxime ont
séduit la fin non mais c'est ce que j'ai
dans tout cela les seuls qui ont
commencé à séoul année c'est maxime et
cramique donc fait les deux qui ont
commencé au cse qui sont en chute et
hockey maxime on sait pas parce que là
il s'est passé pas les officiels ou
coiffés au moins elle en train de jouer
non merci mais même s'il finit le mois
d'août à 27 80 et la gamme 20 points de
retard 20 foyers c'est dur mais bon
après y'a plus beaucoup de tournois
fatah les olympiades et les olympiades
c'est normalement pas là que tu vas
faire le trou non il veut faire quoi
mais il fait ces machins estime que le
field est ou non ouais mais yassine que
finn en outre mesure par là je vais à 27
mais je mets 10 points de plus affoler
reprendre les dix points c'est pas grave
c'est bizarre je n'étais pas au courant
enfin j'ai pas trop suivi peut-être
mieux comme ça beaucoup de joueurs a
quasiment de 8 à un moment ils sont plus
que trois autres au dessus la digne qui
est vraiment pas loin avec 27 97
il atteint par un vrai trou et air mais
j'ai regardé ce thème tout cela à je te
tiens tu me tiens par la barbichette le
premier de nous deux qui rira du coup tu
vois me manon sylvain tirosh fantastique
à nantes y revient toujours
nouzilly de l'air humide il leur est
possible et ses amis sinon la longévité
de celui de leur famille qua none kramix
assurera - les ignares ça me sourit je
n'hésite leur sang froid
il est bon mais huit fois je prendrai
aussi quand même en satin présente un
homme est bien faite soit il est battu
il ya dix ans 97 je crois avec sa boucle
d'oreille
ouais j'ai une
foulée cinq échecs donc déjà 97 il ya 21
ans
donc déjà été pas mal comment ce n'est
pas un devoir type web de galles c'est
beaucoup
d'ailleurs on suivra le match car la
scène caruana en un quai en intégralité
fabien sur la chaîne bitstream
donc ne vous inquiétez pas même même si
a pas grand chose qui est fait au niveau
échec en français d'un point de vue
général nous on sera là pour pour
commenter le match surtout que vous avez
fait plaisir avec avec les tipis pendant
les candidats et c'est vrai que c'est ça
aussi qui nous a motivés fab à
renouveler l'expérience
oui oui mais surface et on voit qu'on
veut plaisir à puis c'est cool de nous
aider parce qu'évidemment on peut va
passer trois semaines à faire que ça on
va pas trop faire autre chose a ajouté
c'est on va pas jouer surtout moi on va
pas de trop donner de cours là pas du
tout donc à côté il faut bien que ça
compensera fin on peut être sympa un
moment mais c'est pourquoi votre faim
sous des ponts
bon très sympa un mini mort de froid
comme il était sympa dommage c'était
bien calmes ce tout jeune mais bon pas
de chance donc chasser une chaîne écho
plus est ce qu'on a vu le sacrifice de
dames de carl scène à ton avis pas le
toque à ton n'est pas que j'aime
beaucoup et plein de gens qui montrent
toujours inquiets puisque tu as vu ça
les gens qui ont écrit sur facebook mais
vu le nombre de vidéos qu'on a fait
c'est même très difficile de nous
surprendre avec un truc qu'on n'aurait
pas vu tous les trucs que j'ai vu en
direct j'ai même en fait le plus drôle
fable là dedans pour le sacrifice de
dame de kazan pour la peine c'est que je
jure bon il a fait je regarde la partie
en direct et je pensais justement
sacrifié en fait j'ai en train de me
demander que faire et je me dise tiens
ça a l'air intéressant sacrifice de
dames non mais là entre
je pense nous préparant pas ce qu'il a
dit en conférence mais ce n'est pas un
caprice de dame c'est difficile en fait
faire les gens sont passionnés bêta dès
qu'on pense en fait de laisse enfermer
la dame etc soir ouais bah oui mais il
retire pas le fou parce qu éviter sa
fortune est on cloue quoi m'arrête de
kuta pas trop d'avantagés et là je suis
pas sûr qu objectivement tel avantage
mais en fait c'est juste évident joué
par noah à ses joueurs afin d'influencer
que les blancs étaient un peu mieux
quand même en tout cas d'un point de vue
pratique je regardais pas avec leur dire
donc mais non c'est cher un jour cesser
lanta deux pièces contre une dame c'est
que tu coordonnées de pierre c'est
avignon où tu le beauf est ce qu'il ya
une dame qui font donc là en fait le
truc c'est qu'il y avait le roi à l'abri
dans son petit château n'est pas trop
d'échecs et tour cavaliers machar
si solide mais le truc c'est quand jack
il ya des compensations mais le truc
c'est que ta phu tho tafoukt à tour
cavaliers piotta 9 points la dame de
neuf points fin fadiouth et pas derrière
matériellement faite donc c'était un peu
d'activité et monte pas l'air
matériellement vas tu es devant un
auditoire c'était pas des noms mais
c'est important de connaître la valeur
des pièces
c'est un peu con dit comme ça mais
savoir compter mais je suis souvent
rendu compte dans les cours que les gens
payent ce n'est pas la valeur des pièces
mais genre noble c'est trop fort alors
qu'en fait alors est-ce qu'il va réussir
à la sauver sarah caruana ouais je pense
quand même mais pas sur eux
je suis moins sûr qu'il ya deux coups
quoi j'aime pas du tout environnement
très bien joué qu'à ic2 haïti des
catéchètes situé à vichy pau orthez pau
de partout le 24e minute mais je pense
qu'il veut essayer de la gagner avec les
noirs mais il va pouvoir c'est pas si
simple ça si tu peux fermement pour lui
c'est au dessus mais en fait j'avais
regardé avec l'ordi une fois j'avais
remarqué un truc marrant c'est que si tu
joues que les trucs logique ça
fonctionne trop rien t'arriver et evry
peut sortir le roi du réseau et ses
filles mais ça c'est bizarre quand j'ai
regardé j'ai été choqué parce que tu as
l'impression que tu peux tu vois si vous
jouez précis en fait juste accueillant
coup logique et ça tient peu tout seul
hier jeudi a great food qui est connecté
futur qui regardent le match qui
grillent aucune connaissance achat il en
train de regarder
vlad lobligeois lille prépare toi quand
on regarde ils sont beaucoup plus fort
que toi regarde eux savent jouer aux
échecs
contrairement à certains mais finira
devant bitstream
peut-être mais toi sûrement pas quoi
ban demandé s'il pouvait gagner autant
le truc c'est qu'il rajoute d'une
seconde comme écrit au dessus de au
dessus de nous il ya les écrits les
cadences un way aller plus haut bref le
bon plan en grains rognant si bien si
vous pouvez sur des cas de ces cinq jugé
que ces quatre noms faut pas faire nous
avons gardé la catastrophe les vannes et
moi je fais trois noms sur des cas céder
4 c 5 parce que je veux rentrer dans ces
des dessins qui est rentré dans des gens
très 44 paradis sont obligés de prendre
oui je sais mais sinon je suis enlevé
trois poisons mais la balle d'âge et
c'est exactement ce que les immeubles
d'une des cours je vois qu'ils nous
regardent en direct d'ailleurs il n'a
pas dit jouer exclusivement le système
de londres donc ils faisaient des 4 5 3
mais il ya un petit problème la commune
parce que foucault mais vivre innoncent
distincts que je n'aime pas oublier que
l'expliqué du coup les valeurs contre il
faut faire ces trois au système s
l'offre d'échangé
ainsi le oui mais c'est pas si mal à
chef des chambres examen ce n'est pas si
tu regardes la partie tu peux lui
montrer la partie socar en scène par
exemple tu avais fait tout seul
ouais mais c'est une bonne partie
personne n'a jamais vraiment égaliser
intéressant face avec les bonnes il a la
classe il joue avec la lumière bleue
genre de truc va finir c'est une
discothèque c'est ça je trouve au sco
peut tout arriver bien avec les blancs
il faut refuser du désistement données
mais je dansais ap un truc genre car
henin ça va marcher
je vais faire qui a aidé ça fout des
quatre dames prend des quatre ou cinq
échecs niveau de prendre b2 peut être
mais pas nous ces trois s'en fout on te
défonce sur 15 mois il reste 50 secondes
dans la section 5 + 1 et ça fait cher ça
fait ça fait 3 points quand même fab
il me brandt assez marrante bazille
problème de ces trois vous prend un full
aux 5 et les fils qui va les prendre
quand on prend dix à lombez de ces trois
fonds prend un coup cinq des six
épreuves on me prend pour prendre 17 mai
prendre notre grande dame prend pour
exemple même si la salle est fort jolie
kate syncrude est qu'à 3h infosys ses
trois bougies
je veux pas son objet moi ça dégage ce
fou de rage aime bien damée de fab ont
atteint 81,7 d'autres c3 20 ces trois
ans apparaît fort puisque qu'elle prend
des cinq puis on prend et les cases
noires
ouais ouais si ça fait plus 4,7 cher ça
peut être très très très cher à la
sortie pour caruana fabien qui attendent
pour 8 6 4 son site pas pourquoi tu peux
jouer l'esprit à fon fabre dame prend 1
8% qui traîne à feindre oui mesdames
produits qui ont francky et prend des 5
c dans l'esprit à fond oui mais mettez
dans les thrillers quand beaucoup
c'était un faux si gentil très bien en
fait le fou est enfermé oui ça peut
faire très très très très chères femmes
parfois qui est le cas ici même et
cavaliers quatre d'entre eux ont cassé
leur esprit a foncé à quoi ce serait
fantastique de jouer une partie campagne
comme ça et tu vas à l'analyse après et
puis tu youyou ya six mois
c'est ce genre rosine de spirit a eu un
super clean tech si fort avec ce de nos
les mecs complètement épuré quoi
conférence de presse jeudi que de la
merde j'ai su prétend me diriez vous si
le tabloïd maureen de stériles than you
enfin furuno the what happens after quoi
fin mais là c'est complètement red five
à faire des quatre jours par semaine je
pense qu'il a pris la call of may 15
mois un pur on passait rien mg 4 qui
arrive lors de ce tueur est encore ces
trois dames dès 4h et je touche pas mais
tout bien réfléchi envie d'attendre les
soupers la fin des marques ces trois
dames des cas des 4b cinq mois je suis
un peu gris kaki adams et cisco les mecs
côté intérieur et pour les sprints
échangeant les dames comme une merde tu
n'as pas le droit humain avait besoin
je ne peux pas faire ça mais ça il faut
se rappeler que les mecs en face de toi
sont pas forcément autant dans l'esprit
que toi
non mais non ils veulent t changé d'âme
la mélasse et ça va être dur un des
cases noires bep cap des 5 6
surtout que vont déjà un pion par la
qualité c'est déjà beaucoup mais ils
sont pas stables je soupçonne qu'ils
avaient plus clair avant ouais enfin
chez catherine barrier gens de chaque
eagle ce qu'on y passe et le chat mais
les gens venir là après la pause et une
pause dans 50 secondes faut se calmer
aussi un non en fait c'est dur de dire
le chat noir mais il faut pas tout faire
en même temps un pour vous compreniez
mois genre l'âge et l'écran de 3 points
comme et je peux pas ouvrir le chat en
même temps quoi
mais moi je moi j'ai le diable norman
nato non mais là j'ai le tchad en même
temps mais le truc c'est qu'il faut bien
que vous compreniez enfin vient répondre
au chat de temps en temps oui mais j'ai
ainsi pendant la partie a choisi louis
la partie intéressante on parle d des
fous des matches a dit aux femmes un fou
sont fous de la partie on compte de
châtelain autant on fait des live chat
le truc c'est qu'on souhaite à nouveau
de shadow dit joue aux échecs donc au
bout d'un moment enfin on peut pas tout
faire tout le temps même temps là en
garde la partie c'est une belle partie
on se fait plaise pas toi j'ai envie de
regarder la partie là ça me fait plaisir
de vazy on regarde on regarde de nouveau
la partie on s'en fout non non madame
d44 noyau b 4 mesdames si ça ça me
faisait chier ce que je peux attendre
faire des cats et d'amuser de maths qui
veut juste jour est à mettre ça derrière
cet échec peut être pas mais moi j'ai
sept fous g7 pour âge et s'intitulant
raison et daniel six matches mais bon je
regarde sait jamais ça m'a refroidi quoi
donc d'accès six étapes
bon on est bien mais dernier un truc
marrant sur dame sait si on s'en fout
hein mais y'avait tourcoing fc 1 co 6
pourrait être intéressant puis on
travaille cinq dames prend avec cinq
échecs et je te maths en force avec mes
pièces quoi d'autre pour prouver de
rester choquant à pranger 2 puis on
prend un f5 dame france et 6 puis on
prend ces six fois fils weeds grave et
tourne autour des donneurs certains
calculs genre de merde et mahamat en
quatre ans rien à voir tous trois baies
netapp des caf ni 4 il faut sacrifier la
qualité mais bon après ça soit on ad'un
d'options passé quoi toi du coup mon
idée de faire des sets live box sécurité
on reparlera dans l'idée 17 qui à mon
avis est très intéressante dam des
cartes des cinq noms j'ai tellement
envie de faire l'arrivée 4 les gens
oublient si une des six dames my beat
peut-être appareil 5
[Musique]
il n'y avait pas eu avant d'approuver
cet échec peut-être pas les dames g7
patins top 10 c'est tout ça serait bien
aidé à manger c'est pour l'aspect 7 3 et
je peux faire des stations c'est dommage
mais ça je suis d'alger c'est 3 bougez
wendy m'avait déjà bien il veut refaire
fou c'est un don qui est fou c'est quand
il veut empêcher faire racheter après
qu'il ait purgé trois matches ou f4 pour
2 5 vous pré inscrire tous mes tours
dessins que c'est pas failli se faire
voir là bas et une tour f1 marche
ça va faire plus + 4 quoi chéreau c'est
cher c'est cher mon femmes
et me sentais fort risque de défaut non
mais ok mais là il va y avoir et ce dès
cet hiver je me supporter ou quoi du
coup c'est en quoi ça m'évoque et lance
alors à temps et ce qui est encore les
960 ou pas j'ai pas bien je crois qu'il
ya plus de 970 et en fin de parcours la
dernière à nice et paris caruana façon
d'écouter mais tu vas tu vois le truc
dont j'avais parlé de faire les 7 et 12
et même en rien très classement mais qui
va voir le jour dans un autre dans un
format sam était confirmé que le format
que j'ai proposé à les voir le jour donc
ça c'est quand même intéressant donc ça
fera sera beaucoup lui évidemment ça
fait beaucoup plus intéressant
forcément ça sent la coupe écoute bord
bip oublie de stream mais donc là en
fait dans mon format bah en fait tu t'en
fous qui a perdu 6 2 tu as perdu et
perdu premier ça a été ok deuxième set
ça repart pas ce que l'on en fait ça
fait cher et problème c'est que c'est
trop cher
ok tu as perdu premier set 6 2 au
deuxième set peut-être que tu gagnes
c'est pas moi c'est sur gary break
bon bah c'est bon enfin elle a la même
faim bah oui ça prouve une nouvelle fois
que les bonbons veut on veut on veut un
temps d'antenne clair et net c'est pas
de suspense qui compte c'est le temps
d'antenne ouais bon alors du coup plus à
le chat noir plaisir
pétitionnaires sécurité par un trike à
roanne aux impressions pas vraiment dans
les faits ils vont vous a dit ça sous
l'angle c'était pas son truc
marc rapide non plus d'ailleurs et puis
c'est pas son truc mais bon c'est son
truc que tu mets des adversaires tu
mettrais 1 2700 en face pourquoi pas
mais la scam à rognan et ouais il a du
mal mais vous voyez un an tout ce qui
est grande pièce tourner le truc comme
ça il finit dernier ou l'avant-dernier
jamais vraiment mieux c'est un peu comme
topalov complètement et je ne peux pas
se rattraper bastien c'est pas fini 4
points à quatre points c'est fin c'est
pas fini si ni la photo va peut être
voir du bullet voir des trucs comme ça
mais il peut revenir mais bon mais au
fait à part mais à l'évidence en plus ça
te met un coup psychologique de bon
c'est comme ça je trouve le temps long
tony mans et ouais c'est ça le problème
aussi c'est pas des parties
indépendantes les unes des autres
c'était une dynamique de match aussi qui
s'instaure et ça c'est dur
c'est dur c'est dur et la difficulté
aussi c'est que le scénario des parties
a pas un moment à le moment là où il ya
eu trois et demi un ennemi là la défaite
après cette défaite là qui a fait passer
à quatre et demi c'était quand même
c'était quand même avec les mains au
regard de la gagner c'était autre chose
d'un autre match mais on a eu un peu de
malchance dans ta peau ni bouger qui
équipa contemponi c'est dommage j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya deux styles de
gens sur le stream et joueur d'échecs
qui viennent prendre du plaisir à
regarder quelque chose enfin commenté en
français et merci à vous et des gens qui
viennent de twitch apporte les mauvaises
habitudes des tchats which pourrir tout
le monde je suis passé à beaucoup de
gens de tweets chose quand même des
pseudos que je connais mais
mais c'est clair que ce qu'on regarde
enfin me fait pas du format est que les
mecs là on n'est pas en train de la de
fin on passe pas notre vie à jouer à des
jeux vidéo devant notre ordi on a rien à
raconter quoi fin car quand tu joues
huit heures par jour à force night
j'ai pas envie d'être condescendant mais
j'ai quand même un peu l'être c'est un
peu tu as quand même rien à faire front
donc là c'est un truc quand même un peu
de votre corps d'armée ok mais je vous
informe nights 2 heures par semaine
pourquoi pas il ya des gens que huit
heures par jour c'est mon nom qui sont
sur 20 ans tu vois c'est quand même un
peu différent pas donc j'ai envie de
tenir forcément là quand tu regardes des
échecs bain par courrier des parties
envie de regarder parce que c'est
beaucoup ou assez de la meinau et
n'importe qui et vous personnellement
bonhomie goûter plus tôt pour les vols à
sare par un fou c'est déjà reparti et
quoi d'autre non merci pour les articles
chaise comme à merci si vous voulez
aider et partager
je redis même si vous amis ne joue pas
pas mal quoi bein je remets un lien
partagé sur le partage et le post
facebook et d'autres lives l'avouer les
oncles les articles oui j'ai fait le
truc sur mv est là à bienne partenaires
partie de ses droits il y aura peu
chaque mois j'espère sera refondu fab je
te coupe désolé de te couper mais il en
train de se passer ce qui se passe
pendant tous les matches c'est à dire
qu'en fait on ne voit plus caruana parce
que comme tous les mecs qui perdent il
se baisse sur leurs chaises et là on
voit plus sa gueule quoi c'est fini
ouais il est il est flasque quoi le body
language quoi ouais donc je laisse ces
caméras parce que c'est vraiment
frappant l'on voit plus que ses cheveux
ou une touffe mes joueurs c'est marrant
parce que c'est à tous les matchs va
danser speech est ce qu'on regarde la
main ensemble depuis plus de deux ans à
chaque fois qu'on met des caméras dès
qu'il ya un mec qui perd on le voit
s'affaisser sur son siège est à chaque
fois mais là lyon voit même plus sa tête
que c'est fini que les bonnes
maintenant il est bien cadré au début
est un peu coupé les ailes et bien cadré
oued semar en quoi le body language
quand même ouais ouais mais
non mais c'est sûr c'est pas si ça use
dans tous les sports à ce propos rien le
body language c'est marrant comme truc
même peut-être qu'il a pas de mental
aussi après mais j'ai déjà tu perds de
quatre points contre aronian donc tu
n'as pas de mental de base et puis là on
voit que tu n'es pas bien et sur ta
chaise chercher n'a pas de mental
c'est d'ailleurs très beaucoup vu
pendant les candidats quoi bastille
avait du mental se battre et tout le
monde a enfin j'ai juste fait premier
onglet de la dernière bataille pour dire
in inside job enfin prié jobs way du
stream en général un pack entre nous un
ses traits à jack chaque fois que je
fais les les machins et non mais avec
des carnets emmener sur youtube ce que
oui les arénas tu as pas de mental ils
vont je suis quand même 4e du classement
général je me suis fait voler deux fois
par le règlement j'ai raté deux tournois
requise aux joues tout est bon je suis
quand même 4e devant kosteniuk hammer
bon ça va quoi je me sens pas en manque
de mental 6 mai sera passé outre sinon
ils sont tus parce que outre es tu sûre
le champion du monde avec moi me regarde
ta partie contre lui car c'est un très
bon mental voilà c'est de là que parce
que les gens qui sont habitués à la
chaîne connaît sont maintenant les gens
qui sont des battants il n'a pas pris la
pièce avant qu est-ce qui a
matériellement la femme c'est quoi ces
qualités des plus pauvres bon ce n'est
quand même pas mal que caruana la gagne
ça c'est on voit de nouveau ses lunettes
ça y est il est pas trop mal il se
redresse pas il en reste un petit peu
mais fait on concevoir des bouts de
lunettes en x16 car on a ça crée une
pièce non il ya une qualité de plus
en train de jouer au jeu des pronostics
à 7h partir mais complètement gagnant
avec les blancs mais bon c'est pas fait
un
mais bon les bonnes qui est pas bien
rentrés dans cette danse est qu'en sais
tu vois le truc 17 juin ok tu perds tu
n'as que gagne premier set est mal
rentré dans le set le magazine a pris à
partie et tout de suite match est
complètement relancé direct anonyme même
5g pas convaincu match d'hier je veux
une mer très primitif j'écarte h4 qui
bloque un peu louche ou c'est pas
chouette hulotte on vous aussi
par là même si damien au jeu des
pronostics ça tu saches que tu es très
fort au début alors attends le truc il
faut qu'il fasse gaffe quand même c'est
pas perdre des quatre que six paires b4
aprilia trois pions passé lié à la
c'est un point de faire exactement là du
coup b4 à attaquer tu peux me faire
tomber un puisqu'à le fou et 5 6
restants prise demain damas alors sur
dan des cas tu veux faire comprendre ici
c'est que la dame protège la tour tu as
le jeu des progrès citant surnom un peu
c'est quoi ce lundi sur ces 3 2 j'aurai
fait tout autrement une coupole hosting
été mal là au jeu des pronostics je sais
pas une surprise mais tu ne peux pas te
prendre du psg 4 damage cas pas tous les
gars vous pronostiquez fait 300 et forcé
mais c'est loin d'être claire safa 20
note c'est loin d'être fait parce
qu'évidemment les blancs sont mieux mais
tu vas devoir faire foule demain
peut-être autour des 1 et le truc c'est
que c'était évident de tous et ont trois
contes de aller droit et quart monde et
peut-être même de faire du v6 et 5
passes et ses pions c'est pas net femmes
non d'accord mais il ya un truc à gagner
jeu des pronostics frêche prend enfin
nantes juste le titre je finis ce tronc
déjà tout de suite non en fait je te
parle c'est intéressant enfin s'il y
avait un truc à gagner revêtu pour f1
fou tu peux rentrer pas quoi sera fait
votre territoire
je suis à fond sans la gagner mais j'ai
l'impression de cajon et malaga nice à
la fin regarde il arrive pc c'est fini
oh là là elle fait mal c'est la femme
bon j'ai gagné vincent 49 ml fait mal
c'est la femme elle fait mal pour
fabiano
franchement non mais le truc c'est que
c'est la deuxième qui tourne comme ça
déjà caronha nez un peu au-dessus
faillir 5,4 c'est pas pareil que cette
de l'a20 par lasser mais c'est marrant
quand même tous ses matches et tourne à
l'humiliation à chaque fois on speed
chasse à une dynamique qui se forme au
début du match et puis après c'est
khalil vomit ses entrailles on a bien la
vraie s'il était au tour de france et ce
sera un peu comme barguil là dans la
montée d'aujourd'hui je reste à regarder
ou comme craddock bruit mais tout ça est
là barrier la vendée où il se dit oui il
ya des échappées jeu pareil que dans la
montée il monte un petit peu avec un
nouveau [ __ ] explosion je n'arrive
plus à 20 je dégage pas la même mais du
coup philippe guitton maïon et wenn
j'aime pas du tout secours à ne pas
perdre un pion genre qu'il prend des six
francisci et prend des 5 ce qui était
allé prendre ici ce qu'un objet de faire
d'un prend cette emprise surprend elfi
ce jeu de faire d'un point qui les prend
des sens l'armée mène moi j'ai vu quoi
faire un jeu fable à 20,6 vlad
t'appelles tu dis même cave avait vu
cette tactique pour vous 3 tranquille a
peut-être fait penser au ko technique à
solder dans mes frappes
j'ai bien fait refaire de m3 tu veux
faire le coup de fouet dimpre emprise
demandé trois tours 8 et full karaté
mais les fruits thé chaud les pièces
étaient contents assez durs les amis
baguet c'est le soir c'est comme ça tu
peux pas avoir pitié quoi faut que tu
viennes que même dire des choses un
petit peu plus vulgairement que sa
famille c'est dans un esprit rugbystique
mais je ne ferai pas a jugé qu'il est
obligé de finir la partie le whip
abandonner maintenant mais ok tu as
peut-être une chance sur dix de sauver
quelque chose donc tu tentes
enfin tu ris fin de cette partie là je
veux dire le match du barrage fuite car
l'espoir a d'ailleurs bon nous on aurait
fait mais elles n'ont en effet si ça
tourne à la con mais ça on a des joueurs
prêtés pour jouer tu peux pas partir
comme ça non mais évidemment je rigole
infâme bas mais après ça aura été une
c'est pas le truc que tu es tu faisais
quoi la plupart tirent en fait très
souvent faim
capcom du stream tu fais jamais mais par
messi je ne vais pas précèderont date à
2 sur 5 tous pas de prix que ça saoule
bat a mieux à faire que de faire les
villes à 23 heures le soir
enfin maintenant je vais dormir qui
avait sorti reprend albert de le voir du
monde matière je dors gsteiger je me
repose toi non mais tu peux pas affadir
c'est comme à roland garros je compte
nadal tu as pris 6 2 6 1 t'as pas les
vitrines troisième set imagine fin mais
c'était alors d'abandonner mais tu es là
du coup cette partie là bas se fait pas
sans abandonner puisqu'il un cavalier ya
puis un 4e encore un peu faible c'est
pas sûr qu'il a perdu c'est pas si
simple mais bon ça veut dire beaucoup
sur son état mental je vais faire bon
c'est similaire
sa tête le fou en d1 faire tour b1 et tu
vois il est tombé 5
c'est bien vous attends tu vas faire
tourbe et a maintenant puisque genre
qu'il prend 1,4 tour 17
ouais bof tellement d'options mais
séparé le fou le fouet f3 il tient la
casse de 2 du coup la tour écolo ne est
un peu enfin sert à rien et il va
réussir à nice à tour en b1 en b 5e jour
il a réussi à faire ça c'est vrai que
l'avait tour bien qu'ils aient prend 1,4
tour b5 et tu regardes le pion à en
force one en berne
ok la tourbe et un cahier prend 1,4
tourrenc pour b2 brasser un ton coin f2
il ya le fou emprise bas mais peut-être
enfin tu t'es pas prêt c'est en fait
pour a4 a5 mélange des genres est
ambitieux on peut venir
est-ce qu'on fait retour peu un marin
scorpène le roi il colmate la colonne
des sur kylie s'ils sont faits four b3
maintenant pas de ce côté là la femme en
attendant un problème nouveau jeu
revient à tout de suite qui va facteur
dans une seconde et donc tour 1 et
latour kikena colonies fabiano qui est
très mal fait rien qui est très mal ay
si si mais le cavalier e 5 de toute
façon il va se prendre du f406 qui les
passants au sein qui va se prendre du f4
ok il va se faire chasser alors est-ce
que tout de suite ou pas on sait pas
mais possible et là j'imagine mares
comprend prend des risques peut-être
prendre de f
pour activer dia touré fitou et ce qu'on
ferme virage 5 pour empêcher parce qu'en
fait comme je vous disais on contre la
colonne b avec le roi et en colonne la
con contre la colonne avec la tour et du
coup on peut peut-être faire du tour
aussi si quelque chose comme ça et et
venir sans prendre option avis après
surtout réussi six as peut-être une idée
cacher que je vois pas immédiatement
mais on a inscrit ses chèques tourcoing
fc tours 6 échecs c'est pour dévier
droit un gentiment
mais ok tour et 7,3 des systèmes
question que je me pose est alors tout
réussi je sais pas une verve quelque
chose qui m'échappe a et tours b 6 qui
défend des excuses et moi et donc trois
des six je crois qu'on a le retour de
fab à l'eau je suis de retour
tu es de retour et donc la tour qui
arrive en bref cette fable vois toi
bon c'est un peu évolué il a juste
rectifier un peu mieux ces pièces saison
mais il défend bien fabiano c'est bon
pour lui ici que je vous nous tourner
vers courage 6 août au 26 juin
ça tournait alors est-ce qu'on fait
froid on revient à couvrir mais les
noirs us comme à s'activer fouet trois
petits cailloux 5 maintenant qui va
traîner où il tournait un cavalier 5 g 4
ok ils s'activent et du cavalier hafsi
ceux ci qui peut arriver pour aller
prendre le pion h5
c'est bien ce qui fait fabiano c'est
bien ce qui fait fabiano fab peut-être
torah êtes des trois adjoints
aie aie aie aie aie aie tour g6 qui
arrive au prochain tour j'ai ici 3e 5
pts 11 points à 6/7 rythme ne faut pas
encore abandonné mais roy c2a il colmate
tout il s'est bien défendu mais j'ai
l'impression que les bonnes et tout le
temps en contrôler un oui c'est un peu
glissant il y une calcul c'est un bon
équilibre reste aussi bien à tours
angers 6 maintenant dans ce sens ouais
mais retour 5 vers tour à tour h6 bien
jouer cavalier g7 tour à vii
il y aura pas tour g ça passe carnage
une corrida quoi voilà ça commence
ça commence à s'approcher de la zone
balle on le voit même plus à l'écran
caruana fait on va plus qu'un morceau ce
qui dépasse il ya un morceau de cheveu
qui dépasse
mais il est plus à l'écran c'est génial
ouais c'est fantastique
enfin à chaque match en fait ils
baissent fait plus sur un écran tactile
touffe de cheveux quand les genres
vraiment tu as un bout de cheveux noirs
qui dépasse si tu ne sais plus si c'est
un châssis ça c'est génial tu vas pas
l'écran mais c'est fantastique va papa
sur le switch jesse com fr va jeter un
coup d'oeil c'est fantastique de le voir
nous voir ce qu'on voit les trouver dans
ces mêmes vues du secteur ouanna ou
enfin c'était un [ __ ] d'accord moi un
mini trail c'est génial savoir oignons
joachim gauck synthé quoi donc ils
divers mais faut que tu te disent qu'au
début du match il était cadré face
calmes
je me pose c'est est-ce que le morceau
noir convoi va disparaître complètement
de l'écran ou est-ce qu'il va rester à
l'écran du match un match aussi en perd
encore 2 d'affilée il puisse effacer
parce que là il fait défoncer et orange
et un très mal placé le roi enfin la
veille qu'il ya antique total c'est
génial il a pas de mental est là et
c'est une merde qu'il arrive il est
numéro deux mondial en fait il ya
beaucoup moins de mental que que tous
les génies du chat coiffe toute l'élite
de la nation est en train de le regarder
et se dit tu n'as pas de mental quoi je
n'ai jamais dû travailler pour en
arriver là tu est une fierté génial les
mecs qui arrivent sur le chat ou qui ne
connaissent pas trop sur le pays pense
qu'on fait du premier degré étaient
comprennent pas que c'est une blague
enfin attention c'est même le contraire
en fait on se moque des gens qui disent
ah c'est dur
ouais alors que leur verse en plus
difficile [ __ ] quand même il ya comme
son petit pion bas c'est là à les
cheveux qui remonte quand il s'est mis à
genoux chat landais si c'est bon je peux
montrer mon front celle ci d'avoir été
autant effacer méchant sylar défoncé faf
non mais il n'a pas les pièces
coordonnées enfin jean leroy j'ai un
regard enfin un regard des pièces justin
trois grands tours j'ai enfin je vous
prends ouais la menace des stats au
quine d'été est jacking dont quelque 400
tonnes mais fou desserrage pensons pas
tout ça va vous 17 pourquoi pas donc il
faut aussi se fait encore mieux merci
car ça va faire un aveu c'est quoi
croteau il reste il reste quarante deux
minutes
dossal asahi là il ay s'effondrer si on
le voit plus une option de cette
histoire c'est un peu excité ex champion
des six wu monts jura laufon
non mais faut voir dans cette vidéo et
ça c'est fantastique
allez il a réapparu et où il apparaît et
disparaît sans arrêt qu'est ce qui peut
faire
quelle tristesse
kefu 17 nous avons ligue arabe le son
pur sang froid sont récurrents brett et
607 il s'en est sorti sur salat pas
sorti pour encore fait mais peut-être
qu'à relief ça le plus tôt c'était
gousseïnov en fait parce que s'ils l'ont
fait c'est la nuit tombée chez lui je
sais pas quoi il s'était de plus en plus
sombre j'avais commencé il est le
sourire
jma il faisait beau chez lui il était
heureux quoi afin du chômage us est
complètement sombre le voyait à peine y
avait une tête comme s'il venait de voir
un enterrement et ampoulé plus quoi
c'était génial
damphousse carlson après le oui du très
bas prix janvier détresse are you may
lose un peu à la flatte quoi oui il faut
tu as gagné quand même 22 à 6 bien ce
que je disais ouais c'est ça mais je
vais bien joué je regagne 27,2 un match
normal
non mais là le truc je sais pas par
exemple le truc un peu intéressant c'est
ce que c'était un système de 7 et ce qui
ce serait quand même plus remis au début
du deuxième c'est sur ces listes sûrs et
en disant c'est un nouveau match qui
commence et la greffe ce que font les
mecs au tennis mme y c'est ce que je
pense aussi
ça permet de casser un peu la dynamique
le début d'un nouveau stade ou de manger
au maximum ouais bah d'heure ils disent
ne pas parfois continue tant les en
dessous dans son interview j'ai perdu le
premier match pas le premier set samedi
après évidemment ben ça tu reviennes
premier à présenter sa demande il n'y a
pas mais bah c'est pas la même chose de
commencer à un 16 0 à 0 mais c'est pas
pareil quoi tu puisses tu sens la
différence maintenant qui était un truc
marrant la jeunesse argent sur cavani eu
4 7 6 en france c'est ton d un airois
airois machin 02 au klube 8 mars est
donc ça veut dire qu'il peut peut-être
faire cavalier 4 il n'ya rien d'ailleurs
mais quand on prend des sites sont
offerts il va encaisser qui à tour c'est
aussi ça qui a été sa médaille de la
ville à baie saint justin ouais
peut-être y ait pas demain de le garder
mais là alors qu ils étaient six l'aïe a
l'embarras du choix et qu'ils aient eu
des 4
c'est peut-être le chip aulas bien plus
drôle c'est que vous avez vu en plus
mais j'ai pas à quel point c'est drôle
de style en même temps à tuer non mais
c'est peut-être pas si simple si j'étais
en train de me dire j'ai vu mais d'un
autre côté là est ce que c'est je suis
tête à deux tu fais de prendre reprendre
et elle n'est pas plutôt autour des 2
tours b si bien mais là les caïds au
game tu veux attaquer de calais sur un
pion il peut apprendre du bureau phil
brock road to comprend d'autres nice
situe à faire des fourchettes tube le
clip justin h 5 h clash quatre cavaliers
est très ami avec le pian et six weeks a
attaqué de front national c'est pas
possible on va faire le tour avec le roi
qui est toujours le cas tu tiens un peu
c'est tant mieux car on le sait le
chipeau il ne suffit pas paniqué je
pense garder de qualité non décideurs
soient dans nos pieds quatre leçons mais
je crois je crois que ce qu'il fait
c'est bien en fait il s'est juste de
monter droit c'est manger qui est des
cinq il va recommencer sur surtout
besoin de ça fait cher on le dit à
chaque ronde mais là ça commence à de
plus en plus l'armée à 6 2 on est en
train de là à dire faut remonter aux
pommes et l'a9 de ces c'est un nouveau
massacre
et là car on ne voit plus et finissent
quand même ce suspense un peu doit très
longtemps tellement banon il sous la
table 9 2 c'est la champion's league ce
soir viser le duff de tonton fait il
représente aronian plus tôt bien besoin
de revenir mais je vous sers avec thé
blanc tu as assez bien ce que tu joues
un bon carlsbad après tu va ramener ton
cavagnan f3 par yachts détroit par
depardon parfois tu vas le faire un tube
éventuellement échanger fut cavaliers f3
qui est sain qui est des trois du coup
tu as complètement bloqué le contr e jeu
et enverra deux jours a eu droit à ce
que je fais souvent ni les bières de
trop ce que vous allez fantasy qui
protège b2 protège b4 il veut sauter sur
machin qui étaient aussi des tours
troyes tours âge 3 ou enfin moi je
considère fin je comprends que ces pages
en vente avantage non quoi mais j'adore
jouer ça non mais malgré ce dire ce que
je dis mais tu vois il prépare le truc
en fait en retour quelque part où on a
besoin
ouais ouais ok et la qualité de jeu
pensé très bien jouer maintenant qu'il a
fait à ercis parce que si ce n'est déjà
fait truc comme ça c'est très bien joué
ok il doit faire enfin bref trois
affaires qui est des 6 mai fouet f2 fou
g3 tu reviens vous fait vieux et pas
vous et 3 mai
parce sur ff de et tour de toi je boucle
qu'elle a tout bouffé tu profites tu
t'en fous tu joues les pions tu vois
aussi ce fait d'armes ces deux dames des
ae et du pylône et upi la tour 2 tours 3
août un tour deux camps même twilight du
pilat de toucher 3 ouais ouais ouais
ouais on se fait tour quatre matches
quatre jours je serai peut-être dommage
cette latitude un match 7 et provoquer
un peu courageux suite était sur le
revenu on paie 1 avec la dame je sais
pas pour ici triplé avec la dame
derrière tu vois j'ai encore pas mal
cette dame à la présure tour eu quatre
tours de et avoir dame n'a envie de me
do j'aime bien des regrets c'est bien
aussi de taxer 4le qui peut se boire
avec le rose je fais affaire le plan est
tu peux même faire du roi efforts de roi
des deux comme ça sur un colmater b2
fort et h80 sitruk g3 pas mal aussi un
pion prends tu es fou prend je pense
l'épisode 9 heures
non mais c'est une leçon là que
l'emprunt du tonnerre venu à l'épaule
store qui coince on va voir s'il l'a
convertie de traders vont servir quand
même le faire sur la chaîne qua non mais
bizarrement des fadas les parties plus
pédagogique comme ça parce que c'est
plus facile à comprendre japon de
tactique de merde là quand ils font
alors partie où est toujours des caf ou
aussi un 4 4 ça donne envie aussi
maintenant vous ramener alan virage 5
ok moutons g4 est bien aussi un des
temps
e
je regardais la tour en quatre pour
faire ça perso mon femmes j'aurais pas
venu me prendre dieu 5 et tous les deux
dans mes fins après ce break et d'armes
sûr qu'on préfère toujours le besoin
c'est peut-être un poil raté un monde
bien que les blancs même pas tu n'aimes
pas sûr même la tour serait vraiment
mieux plaçant le quatre sa série noire
qui se parent est le roi sur le tram
deux ou trois des sept mois peut-être
qu'ils tentaient 5 à un moment donné
lille est sinon je pense qu'il doit
tenter malgré tout puisque si le fait
pas qui se refait visées sur office et
sur cinq des six attendus pour la fin
d'un match où il a un peu dévissé
ouais
alors il change son fusil d'épaulé final
et c'est de faire du lycée tromper
qu'avec mes tours g4 c'était soupçonnant
mais j'en dise que ce massacre peut
influencer son match pour le titre on
n'en est pas du tout mais même si
c'était deux jours avant le match non
c'est pas les mêmes qu'à danser vous
compreniez c'est un peu comme si je
disais est ce que l'élimination de
federer au deuxième tour de roland
garros se faisant fluence et wimbledon
ah non c'est pas la même surface c'est
pas le même jeu on a bien vu avec djoko
il a perdu qu'on sait qu'il est apte aux
encarts de roland il a gagné wimbledon
derrière c'est pas la même chose
je pensais à paris que ma femme ouais
après tu prépares tu relis toutefois
parce que la confiance vient des
victoires appellent les victoires mais
mais ça veut pas dire le match l'autre
ils ont certainement plus mais c'est pas
nouveau qui soit pas terrible en rapide
le sait mais c'est pour ça que je
prenais l'exemple de fédé à roland
garros même s'il m'aidait à roland
garros c'est mieux que pas maintenant
comme ce qu'il veut mais c'est juste
pour dire que ok sauf s'il faut plutôt
prendre 3 au 6 mai et tu peux pas te
reprocher parce qu'elle attendait 6 mai
niveau du cou qui donne bien plonge pas
un homme peut-être trois baies 5
mais mon tour à 8 et
comme ça
là en plus des vans à un joueur quand il
est en confiance il est dur à manoeuvrer
après bien sûr pas si longtemps
confiance en lui il s'est fait mal le
vrai mais ça fera que 9,3 c'est pour
rendre hommage aux 9 3 kw à 12 2 3 me
c'est ça ici c'est l'enfer tous les
départements je représente quoi non il
faut espérer pour le match que fabiano
gagne celle là et qu'il ya une la
prochaine et je sais pas si à 9,4 9,5 un
petit frisson après remonte au fond mais
bon on n'y croit pas non mais en sport
je dis cela car après ça il faut je suis
complètement d'accord avec une personne
le chat qui disent il faut aussi
remettre en perspective que que caruana
garde ses préparations de serre qui joue
pas son répertoire et c'est vrai que
voilà mais je retourne au niveau 4 oui
mais bon voilà que peut-être que on
prépare aujourd'hui
caruana c'était toujours le mieux
préparé du monde peut-être ne pas jouer
les prépas c'est encore pire brûlé une
bonne affaire c'est ma loge 4 h en 4,6 s
est pas encore finie la franchise
9-3 c'est bien la cigale c'est là avant
ce qu'on voit sa tête du cou ah oui
vient de remettre sa caméra pile au
monde tu l'as dit ça y est il est de
nouveau cadre est plein sens paraît très
heureux quand il ya une partie c'est
reparti c'est vraiment marrant ce serait
quand même pas du coup il a du mental
coiffe où il a remis sa caméra ça prouve
qu'il a du mental
j'ai pas dis sans les cigales qui
chantent mon tour de chant bonjour des
poches c'est sympa c'était sous mon toit
partir d'où les signes à partir du
moment où les fourmis commence à les
aider ces régions les fourmis sont très
gentils chante quoi fin je te donne du
pain quoi c'est pas mal f5 ceux sur qui
on prend un point f5 ces deux temps du
mal à défendre a mis à bouger 5
intermédiaire par un jeu aussi l'espace
à rete 4
donc comment tu peux prendre prendre et
défendre éventuellement de tension
remarque on a peut-être pu faire dans
l'autre sens avec chris prisé est fou
c'est simple j'ai peut-être raconter
n'importe quoi aspire à mon sens il voit
son nom pour celui qui est prend un set
peut-être non mesdames ce genre de faits
racistes je vais rentrer chez toi je
m'attends à ce qu'il a accompli
peut-il accomplissions des 5 afin homme
qui est dans les bacs et des quatre ans
le stand bas mais on va jouer une idée
sympathique et des cinq points
questionne vraiment
peut-être que sombrer son destin comme
ça socket mousse donc les gens à 9,4
elles sont soit trop kyodo news
les blues souhaiteraient non changer un
peu des saintes et emprunte sans qu'il y
ait des ceintures aux mains alors d'amd
est maintenant et je suis très fier il
ya d'autres partis regarde b2 maintenant
match un bien fou c'est un fou mais
devrait peut-être hkd h5 et 2,4 à une
petite pression petite pression voici
mon il va garder 4 c'est un peu comme
b21 mon esprit ce genre à préférer le
mettant des deux jambes et deux camps
même les fous géniaux les meufs loin
mais tu veux cache pas qu'on le voit pas
ouais tiens on dégage dit être le futur
disque et par ces cinq jeunes viennent
me parler de la diagonale bon donc je
sais pas je me suis enfin je vois pas
trop la plus value que j ai 30 d'écart
par rapport à b2 mais peut-être que
c'est un truc que je comprends pas tu
vas peut-être c'est un plus email c'est
plutôt ça en fait tu manges pas moi je
diffuse meadows il doit donc je ne peux
pas vous dire mais du coup ça avait plus
inquiétant pour toi et moi que pour eux
quoi tête on comprend rien c'est
horrible
ont pris une seconde qu'ils ne sont que
de 1820 à 4 ce que tu apparais te
prendre b4 machin avec fx options a
d'autres aussi mais aussi offerts par
ces cinq dessins qui a lancé m
dufour des cartes va très bien placé au
final
et prend pas c'est gratuit
tu fais bkc qui l'obtient qui ont placé
un barrage frottage éloigné d'un autre
côté s'il veut faire b 4 c 5
il garde son public bon bah du coup
c'est une façon il ya son de basse et de
l'époque protégé du coup peut-être six
teintes point m c'est simple dessin qui
se sentent l'âme attention tu fais ces
cinq ans de pioncer 5 pourra faire des
activités d'accor tous les cas pour
l'instant ces quatre j'aime bien tu
contrôles un peu las casas 6 tu
contrôles f1 et tu tu enlèves de cette
case de 6 où il était en vis-à-vis en
noir et finalement il peut pas être
attaqué là c'est bien placé
non mais c'est l'impression en fait que
la royale est tellement contrôler dans
ce match là même quand il est moins bien
j'ai de plus en plus pour la france a
new way n'ya pas tous recettes la whey
mais y'a pas moyen de 1 qu'il peut
prendre là nul mais bon on ne trouve que
ça dérange naltet ce qu'il doit faire
avec et blanc du bon pied non ça dérange
parviennent enfin je comprends bien mais
bon vu la physionomie de la partie
ça permet ça permet d'arrêter
l'hémorragie de la partie mais tu vas
sur ce set ce qui m'a mené que 3 mois et
demi donc tu pourrais te dire qu'il peut
tu vois non ça c'est une mission made
for global health
on avait senti dans la rixe n'étaient
pas de meilleure forme mais évidemment
sur le match est déjà jaune on s'enlève
du suspense et ses optimistes de sept 07
heures même nombre aux jo hugh robertson
même balle de match alors que ici contre
renversa il est mené de 25 points serait
rien passé en fait l'autre se seraient
découragés c'était finir c'est ça aussi
c'est l'impact psychologique tu te
décourages moins quand il ya 17 ce qu'on
a dit avant mais bon se répète parce que
mon à la fin on aimerait voir se former
ouais donc ici du coup j'ai 4 il vient
clouer un peu gt1 mais pour reparler de
karwan a maintenu ce jeu
[Musique]
une personne qui nous suit
kim écrit sur twitter si on viendra
londres mais je crois pas qu'on va le
faire on y pense à un moment où le corps
a pas de carte de presse
on voit pas trop le lui qu'on va avoir
un wagon d'un appart à londres non mais
le truc dit-il à paris war ou n'importe
où au fait qu'est-ce que ça change
après je sais que c'est très coûteux
mondial et ça va nous faire louer un
appart pour rien et s'en va sortir
dehors de votre connexion moi je te le
dis franchement je préfère aller me
faire après une semaine de vacances à
lisbonne tranquille que dalle et de
sensations pour être enfermés l'après
midi a commenté le truc
bon ok moi je pense que c'est en outre
un week end mais ce groupe va en revenir
à part les trois semaines sécession mais
parce que toi t'as jamais vue de ma de
champion du monde c'est pour ça mais ça
je peux comprendre mais sinon il n'y a
aucune plus value de façon on n'est pas
invités pour commenter l'événement
évidemment et puis c'est quelqu'un qui
est intéressant ce serait pas nous donc
ça vous ferait et ouais c'est chiant non
mais caruana l'acca de nouveau une
partie partie correcte c'est un peu plus
d'espacé changerait de nom mais j'ai
rien il ya un petit coup de mieux
puisqu'à un moment donné c'est fou
les membres non by c4 c'est pas mal
parce que sur tourcoing 3-1 tu peux plus
faire la prison passant alors là dedans
c'est d'abord prendre c'est sûr mais
surprise et f5 c'est évident courage de
faire quoi il a pesé de faire d'un nul 2
2 mais j'irai bien c4 après j'aime pas
trop dans ce tour mais bon j'ai quand
même envie d'y rester quand il veut
peut-être f5 lui même dans son fond ou
quatre blocs
et bien car franchement j'aime bien les
noirs qu'est ce tu bouges le fou eu deux
pouces et 5 échecs un tout ça ça arrive
vite un ghetto bloqué faut bloquer
réclament d'amstetten leur bloqueur il
n'y a pas de choix beh pendentif herbe
et d'autres membres il va permettre
enfin je sais pas je m'avance un peu
mais là ça sent pas très bon le jeune
pro vélo déjà ma petite dame des cinq
femmes des cinq et une jura double
attaque sur par chance on me donne des
quatre ans je pense que c'est ce qu'ils
ont vu un sachant que là bas il veut
faire comme 17 h du matin et sûrement
ouais mais tu as les cheveux croquis
partager si son corps jetés ici ce dame
des sept tours si ce nom ouais bon notre
absence tombereaux j'ai bien vu la
mâchoire liste à 61 qui pouvait y avoir
des il en avait perdu une comme ça tu te
rappelles quand il avait enlevé la tour
de la huitième où il avait été fait
infiltrer
c'est un peu le même scénario qui à de
rares pour lui quoi bon il tend son pur
3 quand même c'est pas trés mais
maintenant son roi dans des courants
d'air il implique grandi puis là mais ça
peut être la troisième partie et si tu
si je fais trois parties comme ça enfin
vous pouvez gagner un match qu'on bouffe
non runyan qui a vraiment vraiment bien
défendu une nouvelle fois on a fait
venir verser 4 rose troche peu contre
nous sommes centralisées en plus mais
c'est dommage parce que même si le match
vont ils gagnent 9 4
sachant cependant le chômage et la
petite bien d'affilée en liga contre
c'est le même scénario qui se répète
qu'elle n'a beaucoup partie un petit
juste un peu plus de tactique moignon il
voit plus les petites schiphol machin
c'est important médecins de toutes
façons cilicie caruana est moins fort
que les autres joueurs du top niveau
envie de cire des raisons est la raison
ça doit être ça c'est que il a du mal un
autre qui n'a perdu qu'à faire votre
choix ce tour ouais bah c'était deux
pièces mineurs trois pions de vieilles
pierres frappions ou une pièce meilleure
option
c'est chaud face était complètement nul
des prix génie ce qu'une force comme en
mai watson ne peut pas faire la
passerelle est du coup en plus après ça
sous celle et après tu vas lui joué
pendant 150 coût de leurs choses les
mêmes ce qu'ils gagnent pas toi de ce
train d'autres plus tard un passé chiant
que cette rétractation
ça fait une faiblesse comme ça que tu
peux viser là je pense qu'il ya là
perdre encore 1
le purin de il est très bien contrôlé
via pâturages 6 f 5 et vous faire rager
ouais mais j'ai 40 ans
il ya les fous oui je viens souvent
peut-être tourache 8 maintenant passer
de l'autre côté il monte avec le roi
inquiet son plan c qui veulent ils
votent par tous mayroy trois ou quatre
coups des cinq qui fait le truc avec
tour à la suite maintenant pour passer
de l'autre côté avec la tour ça à l'air
d'être très fort ce plan d'un centre au
14e saute un peu à l'agonie mais là un
an
miam elle a toute l'europe ou la
gagnante maintenant les pions trop de
colonne des cas ou encore les girafes
rs5 est ok peut-être faire juste droit
ktf cinq noms du rock trois bons
chiffres à jour
key
ouais ouais mais difficile infâme c'est
pas le timing s 14 minutes de 3003 plus
de il reste peut-être trois parties et à
la chute de sa 31e but nettes mais
j'aurais aimé qu'ils attaquent les
pilotes avec et - 5 - 4 pour on ne sait
jamais mais la moins sept bus des tur à
quoi il y aura douze parties en gros 12
13 12 parties et 10 12 parties en plus
un donc en en ayant sept points d'écart
ça veut dire que ça peut pas durer il
faut qu'ils gagnent le match avec un
énorme écart non mais je vois pas
comment alors que cinq points d'écart
ont gagné 9 3 pourquoi pas la fin à
faire 10 2 ça va être dur ça n'est
impossible
25 devant comment fonctionne le système
de points très simplement chaque partie
donne une victoire un point et à la fin
on compte le nombre de parties gagnées
tout bêtement des nuls 0 5 nuls ou un
partage les points donc en gros ça fait
un statu quo ya combien de particules
attaria 30 minutes de bullet s'il n'y a
pas un nombre de parties the blood live
ces matches là c'est en tant qu'homo
[ __ ] ce qui joue à l'avouer un peu
bizarre pour un sport individuel
quand ça du tout comme ça de partie en
partie mais c'est voilà c'est comme ça
ni mis dans le conteneur
je peux bien besoin de vkp et le pion
papa il est plus dans le match mais b5
des katas 5 à 4 je sais pas banquier
proche 6 un jour vous êtes vous non la
dame c3 est très bien placé en plus gros
toujours pas
et puis on prend toujours à deux et aux
français de retour à éviter on va t'en
dit comprendre faire c'est prendre d'ici
sa sortie à monter tu apprends un petit
bébé devant un problème en fait c'est
bizarre parce que fait le plein ce temps
pas de dessin bessin de b4 alternance
pas c'était assez flou non j'ai dis donc
à roanne on allie le savoir et je ne
comprends toujours pas ce qu'il fallait
l'annoncer sur son refrain de donc il me
demanda fleuve 5 qui parrainait pour
prendre le kg 4 bref de se lever 3 qui
en l'air et on n'a toujours pas l'ombre
d'une menace
ouais pas de mental non mais c'est dur
c'est très dur quand tu sais que le
match est perdu de rester motards voilà
la partie est très triste oui mais bon
non mais je tue agent de me revoir
des fois quand j'étais jeune je vais
attaquer cette année avec les blancs je
n'aimais plus fort des titres émis quoi
toi tu comprenais pas je serai je
l'attaqué mais la bande à quoi j'allais
attaquer et puis j'étais confronté à ce
genre de choses en fait tout c'est juste
la tuque route attaque un truc comme ça
tu as créé un milliard de logos ou avoir
ça arrivait à terme un christ il a un
peu groggy fabing millet groggy il est
ko il est ko debout
l'asse avait un protocole commotion je
suis pas sûr qu'ils reprendraient le
match femmes
un nouvel italienne
à 4
il replace avoir placé son coup versé 2
et jouer avec des quatre femmes d'avoir
on développe évidemment n'est pas la fin
j'en ai toutes ces pièces sur le roi il
va jouer des quatre qui va une nouvelle
fois à 4,5 à 4 - tu te prends pas à 4 da
par des blancs tu as le plus d espace
mais wen ont beaucoup de ces italiennes
maintenant parce que tu penses tu à lui
envoyer h6 juste comme ça qu'on a
larache en confiance non papa maintenant
ben je veux pas qu'a franchi s'associent
autour d un jour des 3,5 soit yacoub et
or d un très bon temps des hommes c'est
un tout un truc comme ça t'en vas dawson
exact tamsyn je voulais fabien la lame
s'en va b3 maintenant tu avais prévu et
puis bon tu veux faire 6 4 je pense
aujourd'hui prendre l'espace petit à
petit c'est dur pour fabiano
non moi je veux prendre du plomb trois
armes
[Musique]
la vie non mais c'est sûr tu prends on
prend 1,3 à gagner le centre bell et
vous les joies que c'est ça un petit peu
toujours ans est soignée toujours ses
cinq verrines au regard des cdc au 500e
5 qui rôde un ep nîmes ça tient à
remercier tous les gens qui nous suivent
fabien parce qu'on est encore 340 en ce
moment sur life est en train de regarder
merci à vous de nous suivre parce qu'on
est on est quand même nombreux on est
presque autant que les espagnols
auxquels il a été beaucoup plus nombreux
donc merci les mecs d'être fidèle malgré
un match qui est voilà on est un petit
peu déçu on va pas se mentir c'est
quelque part prévisible voire
franchement tu vois là avec vos
ingrédients favoris machin c'est pas
pour rien quand on dispose pas que ça
c'est pour le mieux
on a reçu un type mais comme c'est la
chaîne duchess comme j'ai pas le juste
salaire le tout mais ok sympa merci
selon titre un petit don mais vous savez
il y aura d'autres matches sur la chaîne
verra le prochain a relancé le 2 août
maxime contre domingues on vous dira
plus en détail confirmation des dates
mais ses 107 ça il n'aura d'autre avant
mais qu'on fera pas parce que ce sera
tard dans la nuit c'est l'horaire
chinois ce sera une heure à kaboul un
fan et oui et ouais en général 5h du mat
cette chaude je pense que ce sera pas
très nombreux ouais c'est pas l'objectif
de commenter à tout et n'importe quoi
non plus bon bien très bien
9 5 il ya un problème n'est pas trop le
choix de limiter la casse matérielle
même pas mon souci est de 5 promu 6
prend des 3.973 est-ce que tu prends un
accès à tous parce que tu prends un set
tu laisses faire dans le premier set et
5 semaines je vois un bon match et tu
prends et tu prends bay 5-1 fac et gemma
et c'était mieux mais ces massacres de
partout mon fabre a mauvaise soirée pour
les fabiens bon soit la haine étape à
une solidarité inter non il n'ya pas de
ya pas une mafia de fabien lobby fabien
ça n'existe pas ça va être notre pour
redorer le blason
parce qu'à le blason des fabiens
depuis barthez je parle plus grand monde
c'est un peu de la merde quoi tu me
diras les kevin on n'est pas tes kevin
fort mais c'est pas des français qui
inondent hairston fils fait un combo
matrix mais il se prend il ce problème
des fourchettes en f1 ces gouttes
pendant que d'autres sont là que cela
prenne un peu mais non mais c'est
horrible en fait c'est ce que je
reproche à ces matches mais ce format
c'est quand tu es chaos et c'est fini on
trouvait porte et accroît tout le long
et on en revient une nouvelle fois
désolé les mecs de dire voyez des fois
on en revient aux trucs 17 truc 17 même
jeté mes deux sets zéro talent troisième
set qui démarre au pire tu peux un
troisième set up perdu et c'est fini
ouais mais je remets pas troisième
peut-être que tu joueras mieux parce que
tu vas tu y es tu vas et tu vas les deux
roues toilettes tu vas te mettre de
l'eau sur la tête et tu vas dire ok ce 7
juin bien sûr non mais c'est sur ça mais
lloris toujours mardi matin soit plus
simple l'arrimer à ce tour des huit roi
je sais cavaliers m6 échec est d'abord
du monde 30 mai mais tu remarques qui
prend son temps il gère bien son temps
les vents en plus gagnés lentement son
corps me contre 10 points dans ce match
là je pense que dans la tête de karwan
ah c'est pas grave non plus tu vas faire
de très content de perdre donc mon
lentement étudiants - il y en a une de
moins puisque la même dame f5 menace la
tour d'un match c'est tout dans le cadre
d'un match 7 et dommages suite maths
c'est joli ça ailleurs dames 35 1 300 me
sur échec mais bon
dans le premier cas d'échec une porte ou
seimat carrément
ça fait 12 3 fab faudrait pas que ça
tourne ça devient assez humiliant les
vannes qui est passée 3025 en bis était
derrière
mais les vagues qui sera un client et
déjà senti l'an dernier ce sera un
client cette année peter brabeck ni le
spectacle n'est plus là et non je suis
d'accord peter le malheureusement ça
fait un peu plus fin plus nombreux jours
à cette variante intéressante dans deux
ou peuvent être étudiées on va étudier
fabien gros chat qui nous dit que ça
fait cher on le dit à chaque rond et
savait que ça cause ça fait cher je suis
ravi c'est cher mais en fait c'est même
pas tu as comme des fois tu vas me fous
du 4-0 s'arrête pas là fils denis match
meulan pote peut pas dire que ce soit
ses vertes est ce que youtube va laisser
un plot des la vidéo on est ce qu'on va
devoir être un petit moins de 18 moins
de 18 ans u r j'ai peur que là j'ai peur
qu'on soit dans moins de 18 parce que
c'est jean rivière fabien ça fait ça
fait cher pour mieux planter à chaque
fois m non mais sérieux la même moi tu
vois je me dis ah ça caruana je viens
viens faire un match en 10 parties tu as
même mais moi je suis choqué c'est plus
que l'ombre de lui même et de façon même
si la couleur lui même mais quand tu as
vu l'ombre de vlad tu as vu le niveau
déjà de l'ombre
quoi tu te dis le vrai vlad ses oripeaux
étrangers cinq classes protégées
d'autriche à oreille coupée
non mais c'est pas fort à faire des
vidéos pédagogiques sur ce match inversé
alors vint me lev forster place
peut-être notre fusil d'épaulé pour les
master class du 31 ouais d'ailleurs
c'était plein de petites annonces ce
mois ci que nous était pas très nombreux
va pas faire deux master class mais une
mais plus longue vous de faire deux
dates sera qu'une date ça vous avez plus
de temps de faire des barbecues et tout
ça et nous aussi
et voilà et du coup tu resteras le tronc
31 juillet donc si baisse il voulait
participer algériens les mains et sur le
moment mais voilà donc vous pouvez
écrire à la basse vidéo échec @ gmail
point com tu peux te gêne chat à l'écart
mais il ya un truc intéressant la
famille que 12 3 c'est pas pareil que
8-7 n'y a pas de dames un bien petit
chipeau enfin pourtant ces plaisirs fera
un peu fou tranche de 4 sait pas ce
qu'il peut faire et avec f3 et on sait
pas c'est dur c'est dur c'est compliqué
bon au pire tu joues la position tout
juste la rupture aussi graves même est
faux aussi ce faux ici s'arrête
maintenant je sais pas femme je peux pas
te dire barre et non parce que ça
personne sauf aux délicats ne s'est pas
ignorer mais j'y pensais sûrement une
meilleure chance il faut trouver cinq de
moins que tu bloques la colonne des donc
à tapas des 5 pts
mais quand même position difficile du
coup de dexter une position avancée de
cette petite gaffe ça devient délicat
ouais mais ça fait presque plaisir
femmes de voir les bonnes un café dans
ce mariage parce que on a quand même
envie que caruana relève un peu la tête
on veut le voir sur la cam qui veut dire
là on le voit sur la cam là mais on veut
non mais j'ai pas envie tu as a service
une immunisation enfin pour nous
commente justement dray mais voilà la
base on le sent meubles qu'on n'est pas
plus enthousiaste
non messieurs c'est un peu comme le vin
le l'allemagne brésil des finales de
coupe du monde y aura un moment donné tu
fais du bon enfin foot et quand même
content que les mecs marque un but fin
enfin moi j'étais pour l'allemagne mais
j'avais misé sur l'allemagne gagne la
coupe du monde j'étais vraiment pour
l'allemagne légèrement 1 0 2 0 3 et
encadreront j'étais content mais on
servait à 5 060 du lauquet peut-être que
les autres marquent un but quand même un
moment donné on a profité de la guerre
civile quoi ouais ok on t'a pas sur
quatre caractères au bout d'un moment tu
te dis bon c'est le soir oui mais là en
tant qu' évidemment si tu joues tu te
dis ok je vais lui mène 10-0 enfin mais
quand on quand tu regardes même si tu es
plus pour une équipe que pour l'autre
oui bon on sait mais nous allons ce que
par une marque de respect en fait de
jouer à fond oui mais bon
mais si les enfants tu veux gagner mais
j'ai préféré gagner 40 ans commentateurs
un oeil extérieur
tu veux pas que la personne soit soit
sur les milliers quoi la sogedo du cou
qui défend bien son roi a noté assez
intéressant finalement deux mal classés
grâce à ce type où il souhaite pas si
mauvais et là il va peut-être devoir
redoubler
ça exactement et tour c'est un peut-être
juste 3h de et voilà tout de kiev tout
ni philippines pour rempart d'un genre
de remparts et maman faisait du d'amin
d'un médecin qui tuent leur place là
d'un mauvais traitement juste et vite
fin
ouais je suis chaud chaud à boom tour -
utilise bravo soir demain ou alors ça me
fait un peu peur parce que ça l'est mais
je comprends que tu veux faire dans les
six top-5 et chalonnes procès mais ce
que je peux faire foot est roi
je pense ça fout des 3000 wereldhave
système projet sens oui mais je vais
faire tour prend b2 femme je voulais
faire foot est roi et tour des prend b2
et contre attaquer là bas non mais je
suis pas sûr qu'il ait bien fait puisque
tout d'un coup c'est plus si claire bas
je pensais être tombé a été mieux
c'est enfin si cette façon ça va
s'envoler qui peut le faire quand tu
vois après cela permettrait bien ce que
je pense ou qui va se réveiller un mort
un jeune anglais précise sur le foot est
roi mais il a été double échec de
partout des double attaque de partout
double abandon mais il va quand même la
gagner c'est pas
ok ça va
mais on sent que c'est on sent que même
ça c'est boucif 1 n'a peut-être réussir
à le faire tomber quand même dur de
jouer avec une seconde de rajouts et
librement
il reste une housse et le bullet ces
mules ati des marques
écoute j'ai deux joueurs se lève avant
le bullet on va faire un petit résumé
sur le score donc la première section du
match en 5 + 1 était gagné 6-2 par les
bonnes la deuxième c'est chou session du
match aller gagné 6 et demi à deux donc
ça fait 6 2 6 2 en gros et il va rester
une dernière section on voit qu'on voit
qu'il ya à peu près une dizaine de
partis là pour le bullet on va peut-être
aller sur douze parties donc
théoriquement il faut qu'il ya une 10 de
fabiano bon il faut pas prendre ça
paraît difficile mais mais tout est
possible en sport c'est déjà quelque
chose pour noter ou se passe mal
ouais c'est vrai que tu peux aussi ce
jeu-là monte mais on a vu que les vannes
n'a pas fait ça les bonnes
il n'est pas allé jouer des positions
pendant des heures ou quoi non mais bon
le temps n'a pas eu besoin
non mais bon les autres naka et lui est
enfin et riou qui avait fait deux jours
après on se rappellera qu'une du
danemark iran où l'arbitré avait sifflé
un penalty pour le danemark
parce que le jeu avait pensé qu'il y
coup de sifflet final coup de sifflet
demi temps et donc taper le ballon de la
main dans la surface et l'arbitré siffle
un penalty pour ça et les danois qui ont
qui ont compris que le joueur n'est
évidemment pas fait exprès
on veut faire exprès de tir à côté donc
géré par nature en sport tu peux faire
salle mais tu peux aussi faire propre
pas dire c'est comme partout c'est pas
obligé d'utiliser salma les règles même
si je suis a probablement le premier à
le faire mais je veux dire par là que je
te fais une call girl où tu me lis en
plus mais il ya des gens qui sont plus
classe que d'autres et il faut faut
reconnaître enfin gers et ça veut pas
dire que ceux qui font pas sont des
mauvaises personnes quoi servir les gens
qui sont plus classe que d'autres après
chacun fait ce qu'il veut un c est bon
c'est vrai qu'en plus les vols l'année
dernière ici se fait avoir par des
connexions et pau
se connaissent bien ils sont chargés de
russophones quoi lui lui redonne pas la
partie ni rien mais géré malgré ça
malgré des expériences un peu négative
il il reste classe face à nantes à son
honneur des plafonds
c'est tout à son honneur mais c'est à
dire quand les joueurs font des trucs
qui nous plaisent c'est cool aussi tu
vois de de dire toujours fait tiquer de
pâtures critique et voilà delà de
souligner le et soul music aronian je
vois qui gère vraiment bien il mange des
amendes pendant tout le match et ça
aussi c'est un truc on a parlé avec la
ligne il faut toujours se nourrir même
si t'as pas faim faut essayer de manger
un petit peu tout le temps et je vois
que c'est ce que fait les bonnes il
encore en train de manger et pas mal de
fois quand j'ai regardé le pape à
plusieurs reprises quand je regarde la
caméra il mangeait des amendes des
fruits secs et il gère son match même
même s'ils mènent de neuf points tu vois
il néglige pas et c'est reparti avec une
une française des changes
côté multi votants voient pas c'est
chiant sow d'inactivité petites unités
donc et foncé des changes après pour les
960 j'ai pas l'impression qu'ils aient
les trois parties de 960 à la fin sera
vérifiée mais je crois que je crois que
c'est annulé parce que les matches durer
plus longtemps que prévu ça fait
vachement devait durer trois heures
trente avec les 960 se retrouver avec
23h30 maximum avec les 960 se retrouve
avec des matches qui duré quasiment
quatre heures et donc je crois que ça a
été je crois que c'était supprimer
fabien et même si j'aime bien le 960 je
trouve que pour le public tu vois
c'était un peu ça désorienté un petit
peu le spectateur soit quand même
beaucoup de gens qui sont néophytes qui
suivent ses matchs sur twitter qui
découvre les échecs et c'est vrai que
ces partis de 960 du coup ça va être un
public quand même plus avertis donc même
si je suis fan de 960 c'est vrai que ça
c'est je suis plutôt content de voir là
du fait que ça a été enlevé même si
voilà je répète que je me bats j'ai dit
que j'aimais bien et j'aime bien 1960
mais là attention parce que sur rage et
c'est tuera pas d'apprendre 63.6 encore
et qu'il est de placer cheapos de qui
vient réfute avec le roi et le cavalier
bon qui va survivre le pion aux cinq
mortels diane invitons et sénégalais le
preneur un petit peu plus actif
peut-être poil mieux pour le mois
apprend bullet ça se joue sarraf avec
les cavaliers et cinq sont menacés
j'écarte peut-être bon pour le vent
l'apple contraire il restait qu elle
c'est un été et prend à deux donc c'est
compliqué bon ça se défend toujours nous
sommes attaqués vu le niveau de jeu et
la rapidité des coûts et d'un ali cela
s'adresse à un public plus public
d'avertis 20 tu serais étonné bras tac
tu serais étonné non mais quel pilote
durera substitut qu'on appelle un oui
mais il dure à suivre pour tout le monde
mais j'arrive très étonné de voir les
stats grâce à twitch toile on es 350
même pour un match qui est pas mes gains
intéressants et tous et c'est sympa mais
ça ça pourra les noirs sont bien la fin
car non mais j'ai du banik la compagnie
tu paniques
pendant que visez-vous réussi à toucher
une population plus large que que les
tournois habituels au regard sur les
candidats on est à un moment donné 2000
personnes c'est quand même assez énorme
quand tu vois que que sur le grand james
urthaler 300 400 personnes en ligne qui
suivent en français et il n'y a pas de
public dont tu vas y avait des gens qui
regardent sur place ou quoi des gars
comme un il ya qu un commentaire en
français tous sur la page officielle est
là pour les candidates avaient le talent
et les jazz band anglais était beaucoup
plus de long qui commentait et malgré
tout on est quand même 2000 fin 1981 à
un moment donné un moment t et s'adresse
comme un public plus large que les
tournois d'échecs habituel qui s'adresse
à a très peu joué en fin grande
cheissoux en français par exemple c'est
de loin la tour actuelle plus de moyens
et c'est l'équivalent d'un grand chelem
entre guillemets en français taddeo
nuances sont équivalentes à un premier
tour de speechless tu as faim ça fait
quand même un peu peur quoi après ça
donc ça touche un public est plus large
bizarrement
padrixe je comprends pas le truc des
stats which vous ne saurez jamais la
proportion des personnes qui savent que
50 à 2000 personnes et que tu as que les
toits des chèques normalement ils ont au
maximum 500 tu dis que tu as quand même
tu touches une proportion de public qui
est pas habitué à regarder des échecs
nous annonce un jeu qui devrait que de
speechless où les candidats
si tu touches quatre fois plus que les
gens qui ont le plus gros budget
marketing de france et qui en canal+
derrière eux et tout ça tu te dis que ça
touche un public qui est pas touchée
d'habitude et donc qui doit être même si
j'osais cheikh beaucoup plus néophytes
après c'est mon point de vue mais le
demi de personnes quand même beaucoup en
menant à un instant t cr que sur toute
la journée at frais 45000 personnes
c'est avant que tous les licences il a
fait feu et regarder ce qui paraît quand
même assez énorme c'est à dire que
tellement une proportion 80% des gens
qui sont pas les sens et c'est quand
même très bientôt blues mais tu veux
rire avec tes chiffres des néophytes
machado dix huit cent mille personnes
dans le sud ouest france
huit cent mille personnes un instant t
qui regardaient le bon voilà enfin je
sais même pas s'il ya autant de
personnes qui regardaient la finale la
coupe du monde peut-être au fait une
nouvelle fois athènes
allez les mecs ne rougissent pas qu il
te sort définissent comme ça puisque
écrite chasse aux puits soit ça allait
bien fait marrer aussi bon alors du coup
cette partie les vans nouvelle fois au
dessus je sais pas s'il va gagner mais
bon tout cas il va au moins un nul en
poche car elle avoue plus un syndicat
et pas besoin de faire le père pète mais
bon on passe pas si c'est un peu passé
mais ça qui peut peut-être taper un peu
des quatre concurrents à passer pour
longtemps voilà qui est sûrement que
c'est injuste mais on dam des refrains
de captivate d'homs et trois nuls ou non
mais
attend enfin c'est pas fait ce que tu
peux te faire réseauter et du f4 qui
arrive tu peux toutefois six dames g2a
machin cette fois ci ça près parfois je
souffrais fils
ouais c'est ce que je peux faire f 4
airwatch francs 2003 bon va bien je dois
je pense qu'il a tué le match
marguerite est déjà pas mal non mais
c'est il ya le truc après où on s'amuse
comme l'année dernière à sache que c'est
fini officiellement sous sa toque et
2002 vous savez j'ai deux jeux ça se
sent mais moi je veux bien jouer kiev 5
pour bloquer 9,5 avec les plans il va
placer devant un peu trop à quoi bon jeu
de mots terrasse nous comptons que
j'entre française sur ces partis belges
a dénoté jardin de lobby fabien quoi je
vais intéressé fallu enlever une
française vous pour être cachée du coup
way un lobby qui est très puissant
fabien ce lobby des fabiens du coup on a
quand même comme solar a aussi notre
lobby ni qu'il est petit moteur on a on
a su ce sens là ou pas ça a été si
c'était plus sur le lobby frappé quoi
vous ne saurez jamais
bon du coup le cinéma ne peut bien nous
non plus bien
mike sweeney vous comptez les gens qui
regardent et qui n'ont pas de licence
moi j'ai pas dix ans elle fait feu mais
j'en ai eu pendant 12 ans dans le hockey
mais si t'as 42 mille personnes qui
suivent ne me dites pas que c'est les 42
des personnes celles qui jouent aux
échecs souvent enfin régulièrement en
france c'est juste pas possible
bon il défend tout rejet inquiets et h3
et je dois prouver à ceux qui fit non
mais enfin j'ai trop strict aux guichets
communs mais il craque fable maintenant
j'ai un bail toi tu es un cas pareil m
si même cela il l'auteur s'est bien
passé des choses à redire sur les axes
routiers
c'est compliqué femme qu'est ce que tu
vois moi je suis très énervé quoi si je
faisais ça g13 a souri quoi je serai à
mes tu peux plus tu peux plus tu peux
plus vraiment là il va peut-être pas la
perdre
m non mais ça va surpasser de partout
briques même en faisant ça va mais bon
j'ai tellement il pousse toi
park et j 7 3 on se prendrait
l'opposition mais c'est génial
ceci c'est un gars assez 5 mm et
recettes du 23 août anne decis avec
fantastic cette partie cédant une partie
de mer 06 les 26 mai fabien nul en fait
plus que youtube
il menace rien a qualifié cette
tranquille dans le plus petit par
ailleurs investi c'est génial que parti
cet appui à une partie du truc d'un à
six et la vitesse du costaud la marche
de l'empereur un blanc
c'est magnifique ouais ok ces deux là
c'est la partie ferdinand notre rapport
au master classes parce que nous c'est
d'être trop année valiant est bon on 22
trop du métal dans ce match non mais
c'est vrai que ça fait plus 10 et ça
fait cher que fabien
non mais un joueur de ce niveau tu
t'attends pas quand même avant le match
qui prennent aussi cher on savait qu'il
n'était pas devant mais mais monte pas
obligé de te faire massacrer un pyjama
oblige nos talons mais sait on a tout
dit après mais on peut pas se réjouir
fabien nombre jour n'ont jamais quand
bébé est un joueur qu'on n'aimerait pas
au vote on a vraiment rien confirmé ben
moi j'aime bien vinolas parce que
j'aimerais nous c'est le lobby [ __ ] si
tu veux donc c'est un lobby à la crise
ne se cache pas comme le lobby fabien
levier [ __ ] un avis très connu et oui
il a quand même quitté de la patrie quoi
mais c'est un infiltré enfin il triomphe
les piments s'est infiltré cette
attention pour cent par année encore
l'événement ce parti peut être dangereux
pour lui à liquider les tours vont déjà
spécial plus dangereux je suis le lobby
de la lasagne mais bien sûr mais bien
sûr d'ailleurs prochain stage en pensant
en italie monstre à mort un enfant de un
peu moins peut-être ne sera pas d'autres
faits de swap en 2018 en tout cas ne
s'avance pas trop non plus donc on ne
sait pas non à tuer présenté le 18
annonce est même 2020 enfin je sais pas
ah oui voilà les 1018 sûr que non enfin
mais mon avis 19 ans fait soif mais bon
peut-être que oui on sait bagdad
mais hors bourse en italie dans la mère
patrie
une influence c'est bien on a poussé par
son tas de sienne palanque sens un peu
plus petits vérone aussi très jolie n'a
pas très bien
je serai bien faut qu'on prévienne
centre est ma région c'est un peu chez
moi c'est un peu mes racines cas pas
loin de venise ça peut être sympa c'est
qu'ils veulent et peut aller passer une
journée à venise pendant la gondole mais
c'est une belle ville venise moi je vois
way we dont ces jeunes éditions mais
j'étais beaucoup plus d'impressionner
par rome en fait les rams mais oui je
sois bon vaty comptable les gouttes vers
rome
jérôme est étouffé un bois où tu as ce
choc venise non le mexique dans les
endroits pas mal pas très cher tu as
aussi rimini en italie marco pantani
je connais rimini vrai c'est un peu au
sud de venise un choix que compétition
ça n'en reste pas lointain on connaît
cette région
ma famille vient de là bas bon j'adore
l'italien j'adorerais être allé tourner
encore c'était bien à froid je retourne
faire un psychiatre a manqué non mais
l'avantagé thalys et que tu manges bien
les gens sont toujours sympas il fait
beau fond c'est cool quoi les âges sont
bien va ça mais ce que j'aime bien la
sienne si je disais ciel c'est que tf1
ok c'est pas florence où tu sais tu as
beaucoup quand même de deux touristes
mais tout ça c'est un peu resté une
semaine c'est un peu mais sienne c'est
un peu moins touristique n'est pas été
pas loin de florence était pas loin de
pise aussi à la tour belle et jolie
quand même cette tour de pise battre à
droite ouais tu l'as déjà vu ou pas tant
bon c'est joli en fait c'est vraiment
joli à regarder
tashi nkwe terre est aussi chievo je me
suis les cinq jeux mais bien que je me
blesse ça redonne aussi femmes ok ça
regretter mais c'est un beau pays un
déjeuner en calabre
je fais plein de tendre un non mais
enfin tu pourras pas me faire dire du
mal en fait c'est ben je ne cherche pas
aujourd'hui je pourrais pas de
contredire la femme je viens de
construire mais là je ne peux pas être
un non nous n'allons pas ce que tu me
contre eux c'est pas des voitures je dis
je tiens à te dire un truc je te repris
là t'es sur qui s'est pas construit des
appréciations faisant du bien de
l'italie la hat très qualifiant ce bon
alors là et fabiano et ce qu'ils disent
bien de l'italie où est ce qu'il y à
mesquer plutôt américain dans cette
partie où plutôt italien simple la
question qu'on se pose enfin voir son
match qui est très américain
il va quoi apprendre le kung fu 4
bizarrement mais je comprend enfin quand
je fais ces arénas qui dure des plombes
que ça se passe mal on est tu tu arrives
plus en fait c'est t'as plus envie c'est
tout ben moi je ne plus bien parti - la
moyenne moi parce que j'ai pas envie dès
le premier coup en fait donc mais je te
comprends affable ah tiens un petit pot
va rien faire et je sais je vous avais
envie de dire ça fait chaque jour
ça fait chier ils veulent pas à
s'inquiéter
je pense à 3h 4g cat et tu claques
non mais en plus il ya des pièges à cons
là dessus mais c'est triste
non il est à combien leurs cornes on est
très loin du record en fait très très
loin du record
cki de records c'est cap c'est karl
scène mais je sais pas dans quel match
torah 5 c'est bien jouer enfin on est
plus tu police ferait pas ce caractère
et gagner là bas si l'on trouvait faire
l'an dernier mais je sais pas si c'était
au temps du ménisque wifag va prendre
contre contre caronna camera par les uns
quand tu prends cher contre caruana qui
prend cher contre tout le monde ce qui
avait pris cher contre nac à l'an
dernier aussi bien contre nakache fois
qu'ils avaient fait match nul dans le
bullet c'était plus accroché que ce soit
sembla je crois qu'il m'a en pls suire
complète et en plus cela orient il veut
être la main du parti
il sait qu'il peut se lâcher mais envoie
le pion à chambouler qualité non mais il
est plus dangereux qui al'habitude
encore pranger 5
on peut se dire plus c'est farid hadj
action pour la qualité mais le caillou 5
est tellement beau matin on a surtout
fait froid et et tu peux faire d'un
métro à damas jockey éducatif est
d'amener avec les jets 4
ok tu as encore tenir kg 4 x 3 et banque
est fait d'un mage en premier cette fois
je crois maintenant bonne kg katina
lynch 6 étoiles 6 et fort femme d'un
projet 56 comme ça en oeuvre jusqu'au
jour
ouais mais là tu fais peut-être il faut
prendre trois points faut être fin mais
ça passe au fromage ou le plein je sois
plus forte dame
shaghai j'écarte ouais mais bon c'est
fait puisque 12 à 9 soit c'était bien
certain pour le master class à porter by
saint benoît en outre tango non mais ok
c'est bien quelle horreur c'est dur
quand même
hu il assure même temps ils sont très
bons c'est le but le tout il reste je te
dire ça tout de suite j'ai pas l'écran
ce que j'ai la partie à l'écran il reste
10 minutes au pied ça va pas selon mme
rochas et le problème en fait je
reproche au sida je sais pas pourquoi
tous les autres sinon allez ça c'est bon
pour moi non ici on met pour nous quoi
je parle pas que pour le groupe
non mais pour laisser pour que les
organisateurs y avec les hôtels c'est
plus facile lors des sponsors ce que du
coup ils rasent est-ce que tu dois payer
ton logement pendant une semaine elle
est là l'idée des aubaines une semaine
en fait mêlée pour les joueurs c'est pas
ça va amener des fois je pense aux
joueurs qu'aux je sais pas ils sont
contents je vois une semaine leur parti
dont 60 sont pas toujours conformes et
toi non mais t'as 90% des joueurs ils
sont heureux bationo ça se passe bien
tout ça tu vas tout ramener ces
sinistres et tu fais un bon tournoi en
fait ça durerait que quatre jours au
site a aussi fait un bon taux serait
aussi notre chance c'est le seul sport
qui fait ça individuel
katia le golf aussi mais c'est un peu
différent ce que c'est c'est du chacun
pour soi le golf des proches son
intermédiaire je me disais mais qu'il
prend et finitions j'avais vu qu'il est
proche est croisée qu'il évitait mai
mais il voit plus rien c'est ça aussi on
arrive à faire flouer 4
du coup le temps de souffler l ai pas vu
ça non mais voit plus rien au sol je
comprends tout à fait la sensation
non mais c'est un jeu vraiment un genre
de cas où on quand on est quand on
emploie ce terme sais c'est un peu ça
évidemment ça pape n'a pas pris un coup
t'as pas pris un coup physique n'a pas
pris une droite mais tu peux plus tu
peux plus tu peux plus mais heureusement
qu'il n'est pas en train de ce crime et
a basculé sur le schatz enfin moi je me
ferai insulter sur le chat la brigade
mental tu es nul ressaisis toi qui n'ont
jamais joué bah oui évidemment non mais
quand à jouer tu comprends c'est fait je
compatisse et c'est horrible ce qui lui
arrive
c'est une des sensations les plus
désagréables caillage s'inclinant très
rapidement et du thé riches et 3
c'est un premier pas mal aussi voilà
fabiano fou qui se disent tu reste six
minutes là il reste quoi il reste même
pas eu à ce qu il y aura sept minutes
allaient gérard semble par avance sur la
situation ce truc se donner un objectif
se dire aller à partir de maintenant
enfin je fais 00 ou quelque chose comme
ça ouais matelote élections qui te dit
que le système jc plus précis que le
système à élimination il en fait ben
t'as moins de chance dans le système
suisse que le système à élimination
n'est ce pas sûr qu'il soit vrai et en
plus quand bien même fatiha pas faire
rouler sans système est plus à l'abri
des tirages ok mais en fait on est sûr
c'était me suis tu peux aussi avoir
détient en fait ce que je comprends pas
c'est que nos échéances on est parfois
j'entends souvent ce ce que je comprends
je comprends ce discours de dire voilà
on veut éliminer la chance c'est pour ça
il faut qu'ils aient plus de parti et
tout ça il en fait dans l'âme il devient
résident joint du plaisir parce que je
relate en train de regarder le match
pourrait très bien travaillé ce serait
quand même beaucoup plus intéressant que
perdre ton temps à regarder ça tu as si
on pensait que à l'efficacité à c'est
beaucoup plus efficace
on va pas sur la semaine à 79 à 70
heures par semaine de travail parce que
se reposer ça ne sert à rien le plaisir
ne sert à rien donc on ne faisons que
des trucs qui nous font chier mais
soyons ultra efficace ses patrons
l'objectif de ma vie mes jambes sont les
échecs parfois on a aussi un peu ce
discours alors après je dis pas que
c'est ce que tu veux dire par là parce
que je comprends tout à fait ton
argument mégère paraît que le discours
du croisy ray mais tout ça c'est aussi
important quoi de fuite
je pars pas parce que tu en penses je
suis bon jour sont en forme
non mais en fait je peux pas comprendre
ce qui se passe ça tout le temps comme
ça que ça change jamais mais ok j'arrête
les saultois pas sympa sur un week end
laissant un peu moins de 2002 donc quand
même pu faire tuer par moments mais bon
apparemment les gens trouvent ça très
bien ça très bien je peux plus
travailler donc n'a pas été battu
sur plus de 1200 koschek crois que 3 1 3
et 4 ses qualités de marché aussi bien
pensée 4 maintenant sur échelle ces deux
échecs
armand tactique il est bien les conclu
ces parties là d'attac ou ok tu sens
qu'il ya un truc mais des fois donné sur
pattes parce que moi mais lui il voit
mais il n'y en eut une confiance
il ya tout qui passe son adversaire et
quand plus rien fable ac c'est du pain
béni pour un jour du str la femme c'est
impressionnant non mais bon il a tué le
match tu le game il a tué bientôt ce
match mais il n'a pas on sent quand même
le mental du champion 1 il n'a pas
desserré l'étau jamais les taux est
resté bronner âgées vers l'autre un
gentil conquois non mais c'est beau
c'est beau femmes et vieux
c'est beau
ils vont dans le travail et au corps je
ne sais pas quel point les mieux
objectivement mais en fait c'est super
chiant quoi tout vient se placer sur les
bonnes cases il te fait c'est encore
souffrir et toi ça va de jouer trois
heures comme ça pas mal marque
je peux le cette partie là en fait c'est
juste que tu as même pas envie de la
jouer tu as même temps minuté
c'est tu t'en fous fait officiellement
une fourchette on n'en parle plus près
bon il va tellement de 30.4
je suis pas fan j'ai compati j'ai hâte
pour pour fabien que ça s'arrête quand
même parce que là je sens qu'il va se
prend un nouveau chip au nom mais pas
balzac face à courtrai et sur orge et 3
machin de préparer un bon coup je sens
qu'il va perdre à l'otan va venir
changer trois mois n'ont pas trop rires
non mais c'est bien bien bien fait de
devoir faire h 3à lecture voirie 6 c'est
surtout la vitesse à laquelle ils voient
un qui m'impressionne la tour j'ai trois
tours g5 qui arrive mais c'est tellement
fort fab
ben c'est un tour de force qu il en
train de faire c'est pas le tout neuf
ans c'est le tour de force quoi il veut
pas prendre une découverte mais mes amis
non il n'ya pas les cloîtres l'ag s'est
arrangé un pardon varié sur le clown
juan plus beaux théâtres prochain
peut-être enfin monde y croit que ça
fait un bond le dit même plus tu as well
quand même croire 12,2
ra 5 le compteur de fabiano reste bloqué
à cinq britanniques cinq ennemis
j'arrivais dire est ce qu'ils vont lui
épargner une dernière ronde non il va tu
minute trente du chocolat dégage et elle
comptera poker est aussi venu 35,50 quoi
qu'il arrive c'est pas comme nos arena
trucs débiles s'arrête pas mais j'aime
bien que ça s'arrête
les prix des criques or là c'est la
semaine mais lundi j'ai décrit corps je
ne voulais pour plus rien je le contrôle
ou turque
bon je n'aime pas trop parce que jamais
un cri corps est en fait le turc il a
besoin d'une nulle pour bat pour être
devant krikor en fait ce qu'ils sont pas
clients un point deux mois il va prendre
un point en faisant nul puisque le dois
accepter et moi a logiquement je dois
vouloir prendre un point et prendre nul
et voilà mais bon j'ai envie de faire
chier quoi vous propose est nul je
refuse je refuse
et du coup je ne pouvais rien faire
j'attends je ne joue pas ça il est fier
3e et de prendre 50 dollars il a fini
quatrième et n'a rien gagné et j'étais
heureux je te fais chier quand même même
le tour a perdu je suis encore là pour
tenir coi fait très attention et imagine
le bonheur non du coup tous les arénas
tu peux quand même très petits objectifs
comme ça numéro 6 sorties non mais
n'importe qui ont fait pas qui tu as
envie en fait à la lutte j'ai envie de
finir parce que j'avais bien krikor mais
si tu veux pas lui a personne qui
voulait nuire mais j'ai regardé le
classement et j'aimerais que derrière il
ya un mec que j'aime bien bon goûter
enfin tu tu ne gagneras jamais quoi je
suis tu n'auras pas de nul tu n'auras un
bon c'est fini fab septembre ni donne
l'option l'ouverture de cinq attaques de
frolov une peut-être finir sur une
victoire
c'est bon on s'est passé c'est peut-être
que je souhaite que leïla une envie
c'est de proposer nul et vous êtes
histoires proposées nul juste et faire
jouer ça
les gabions ils sont très énervés projet
propose ni les enfants ni clicquot même
kevin aurait fait mieux que toi
oui je comprends les lacunes que j'ai
pour réussir à battre magnus carlsen
mais grâce à la force de l'amitié j'y
arriverais olive et tom je pense qu'il
aurait nous sommes donc je ne suis pas
ça un jour tu penses à la force de
l'amitié et tu fais une remontée tada et
tu gagnes 14 parties ont eu une minute
trente est fou oui je te faire ça pour
mon coach quoi je veux faire ça pour mes
amis
le ballon est mon ami mais c'est
tellement génial cette série stg du
grenier en plus nous disent voilà le
truc
y'a pas tomber cette la preuve trois
tours 17e le maire de fismes et je sais
pas survivre imposition
trouve quelque chose
tu peux pas facile c'est comme ça de
l'argent tu as le perdre ton concept si
la gagne pas assez cassé toi pour penser
ça c'est nul tu ferais pas mieux pas
remontée sur qui est mieux avant avant
oui mais non j'ai pas mes propos tenus
les vingt g20 va te reposer pour va
dormir
ok
mais peut-être le faire tomber quand
même et donc des prénoms
ça va être dur contre nac ainsi leur
encontre chez von parce qu'il m'a pas
l'air d'être sûr de lui quand il a peu
de temps sur la pendule et contre nacala
serait pas bon ok finalement peut-être
pas mal ça finisse là-dessus femmes sont
absentes restée coite sur vos jamais sur
les décors de fabiano de grève
il fallait bien ça pour y est quand même
sinon il a gagné pas de salut les
chaussettes mais bon au moins tu as
gagné une partie à la fin et tu finis
sur une bonne note
affable et vonn qui sera un qui sera un
gros gros gros clients voilà son nom de
bain il joue bien c'est quand j'entends
pour le jaune alors je vais te dire ça
si j'y arrive je regarde le tableau que
je vais pas vous mettre à l'écran juste
de regarder moi puisque la ja pas vous
pouvez le voir sur la chaîne il jouerait
le vainqueur de guiry ma mère va tout le
temps ouais et puis guiry peut être
enfin ce sera forcément un match
difficile au prochain tour et après ils
joueraient le vainqueur de alors s'il y
avait une des vainqueurs
il a peut-être une demie contre naka qui
se profile donc compliqué mais les
bonnes mais qui toquent à la porte quand
même un psy qui sera un homme c'est
vraiment bien il a besoin des joueurs
les plus faibles à mon avis du tournoi
mais ok ça que quand il a peu de temps
il peut pas nier que la souris oui notre
faiblesse contre lénine à cannes pour
maxime ça peut être une faiblesse
ce sera une faiblesse c'est sûr après on
tactique par contre il s'est montré
impérial non en stratégie du choc que
c'est bien les pièces il a bien dominé
les lettres bien joué franchement
franchement c'est beaucoup ouais bravo
bravo quand même à fabiano qui malgré un
match difficile va rester là haut que je
suis retrouvé à répondre aux questions
d'après match et tout ça une autre
sphère que là quand même essayer de voir
à quoi deux il a fait ce qu'il a pu
enfin chercher c'est difficile et tout
mais on va y rester jusqu'au bout il a
essayé de ne pas faire des nuls est la
même là d un parti donc en essayer de la
gagner donc malgré le fait que tout
aller contre lui et qui et puis ça
marchait vraiment pas pour lui
aujourd'hui mahila il a voulu donner le
meilleur de lui quand même et bravo à
lui pour ça quand même sur ce banc à
écouter demain sur la chaîne bitstream
donc vous allez voir nous ne citez pas à
vous abonner à flot la chaîne gesca mais
demain sur la chaîne tweet du blitz
stream vous pourrez suivre à l'aréna
qinghua partir de 21h et la semaine
prochaine lundi et mercredi les arénas
royal et dans deux semaines les grandes
finales 2
du streamer championship dans deux
semaines c'est la finale et que les
meilleurs de quoi devenir du dollar
ouais non meilleur il y aura les 16
meilleurs dont meilleur film et
maintenant on va trouver proche de soi
rubinstein c'est bon quoi juste que je
le rappelle il faut que je joue et 4 ce
que je vous des 4 contre l'hymne feu ici
c'est du coup je transpose pas dans ce
que je donc ce que je veux faire c'est 4
à le faire le truc de vlad met donc
voilà donc sur ce merci à toi fabien et
voilà on retrouve bientôt sur be stream
peu partout écrivez-nous souvenez vous
donnez adresse mail via sociaux tout ça
à bientôt
à bientôt tout le monde ciao ciao